all right everybody we
simply cannot wait any longer there is
too much to talk about
it is vp debate day tonight will be the
one
and only vice presidential debate
between
mike pence and kamala harris it's not
kamala i will not be doing a gregorian
chant of her
name mispronounced as donald trump has
been doing
at his pre-covet rallies we also have a
new video
fresh video from uh captain covid
himself looking
not only orange but orange and bruised
from the white house which i will be
playing for you
a little bit later we are monitoring
multiple streams
we have so much going on and i i do want
to just get ahead of a possible problem
the weather is very very bad in new
england today
and there are many people in the region
without power
family and friends have lost power and i
am hoping that
it will not happen to me during this
live stream that would be absolutely
horrible we want to be here fully
and powerfully uh for the for the entire
debate which starts at the top of the
hour so we've got about a half hour to
talk about a lot of different things
also very very important i will be
debuting many of you have heard the song
plasma by joe woodward one of our
one of our great viewers an original i
think it's the song of the summer quite
frankly
joe has released a second track called
don't be afraid and you might remember
donald trump saying recently don't be
afraid of coronavirus don't let it
dominate you
so i have a second track this is this is
potentially a grammy level work
which i will be debuting for you before
the start of the debate if things go
right
if things go right but
we we will see about that and more songs
coming so before we jump
into some of the memes videos
songs and images that i have for you
i want to let allow more people to
connect and so
i'm going to just start looking at some
of the messages that have been coming in
i want to say thanks to kelly wiegand
who subscribed via twitch
who says your channel is the only way
i'm able to get through this election
thank you i appreciate that i'm
inconsolable a top gifter of subs
on twitch says what a ride you've made
it bearable and
shockingly fun that's good if we can
tolerate
the insanity learn something and have a
good time doing it
you know you got to take your wins where
you can get them i don't i don't know uh
i don't know what else to tell you
uh let's see what else do we have going
on
let me look at a few super chats here
and a lot of them have already oh wow
look at all these
youtube members that have come in
already that is insane
wow let's focus on the super chats
though wow that's dizzying
a dizzying number of youtube subscribers
where where are we here we go
chakuseki says i wonder if mother will
make
pence done his chastity belt on stage we
wouldn't want him to behave improperly
because of another woman now would we
yeah listen should this debate even be
happening i mean fortunately they've
agreed to plexiglas but
in all seriousness does this make any
sense during a pandemic during which
super spreader captain covid also known
as mango mussolini
also known as the tangerine terror has
spread coronavirus he likely had it last
saturday
he likely had it on stage with joe biden
on tuesday
should this even be going on uh it it's
very unclear to me very very unclear
chakaseki also chiming in with the
message does regeneron give you
addison's disease because trump looks
more orange in his latest video
than jfk after a cheese whiz wrestling
competition
very well said yeah we're going to play
that video but trump is looking more
mango
than ever and i will not be voting mango
this this election brian says david
shouldn't biden insist on a full account
of the timeline of trump's infection
including dates of tests before he will
agree to be on stage with him
yes yes yes yes and in fact let's just
do that briefly i do have some video
check this out this is mark meadows
again ask the simple question when did
trump
last test negative and uh he just won't
answer
and there are a lot of things we still
don't know we're listening to the
physicians and all the statements they
put out but
we don't know when his last negative
test was
will we well we we don't normally get
into the
the testing protocol for the president
what does that mean normally it's like
as if
it's typical that they have a policy for
how to handle testing reporting during
pandemics for the
this guy's been in his job what six
months obviously the doctor has already
spoken about that
that it was a positive test on last
thursday evening
right but the question is when was the
last negative test not when did trump
admit to a positive
test he was confirmed to to have
the coronavirus and obviously
the the doctor here the white house
doctor kicked into gear with
making sure that he was protected and
and had the the medical treatment that
was proper
i i can tell you that uh from our
standpoint
uh i think the the doctor put out today
uh
you know that there were no antibodies
with the amount of uh
review that was done that yeah this guy
he's just blabbering and blabbering and
blabbering but the answer is
he's not going to tell us he's not going
to tell us when donald trump last tested
negative and every indication that
donald trump
was likely contagious on tuesday of the
debate
whether he had tested positive at that
point and they decided to hide it we
don't know
but certainly positive uh certainly
contagious by that time according to
every doctor that i have spoken with
let me say thank you to scott
fredrickson who is supporter
scott you're a very special person today
scott is supporter number
one during the stream we had 338 last
debate
uh a journey of a thousand miles starts
with a single step
and scott is that uh first step today
uh also thanks to cobffe drinker for
subscribing with twitch prime as well as
vargos
upnup and titan titan or titan
unsure exactly on the pronunciation
there unknown prodigy says off topic but
great job interviewing the mooch good
job letting him speak interview revealed
a lot of interesting info
yes yesterday i interviewed anthony the
mooch
scaramucci the full interview is on my
youtube channel
and he describes what is it like behind
the scenes when trump lies in public
and he des describes a confrontation of
trump
after trump lied in public and it is
very interesting i encourage you to
check it out uh very
very compelling stuff chris hawkins says
what's the probability that trump will
be physically about to do the next
debate with biden
trump will be physically about to do the
next debate with biden i'm not sure i
understand chris but
from what we've been told biden trump
plans to do the debate
that's what uh that's what we've been
told so far
henry hank jones sends a congratulations
chris says oh i meant
physically able physically able okay
yeah i mean listen i
assume that trump is not going to want a
drug test if he makes it to the next
debate let me put it that way
um but i would not be shocked to see
that debate happen
clausable says how's it going going well
sam says watching along mate best of
luck with today's nonsense anything in
particular you'd like to see asked from
both sides of the fence
not re what i want to see is kamala
really sees on the failures on
coronavirus
because almost no matter what mike pence
tries to attack her on
she can say the the infection that has
that you is this the czar mike you were
the tsar
you allowed your boss to get the virus
you allowed
half the west wing to get the virus and
you allowed 220
000 people to die you have no standing
and you
it is an emergency to remove you i want
her going aggressive kamala's very good
i assume she will be well prepared but
you never know what
mike pence mike pence is going to come
prepared with something he will come
prepared with some misdirection
some red herring some straw man or straw
woman or straw person
and um hopefully kamala is prepared for
whatever
pence throws at her we will see
jess says thanks for my work i
appreciate that
david r says hey david with a 20 super
chat 20 the most powerful super chat so
far today
david says hey david watching the rising
show
and reading other commentary they think
biden has done no campaigning and hasn't
talked much policy
so he brings no progressive change this
is wrong child care
tax energy i don't watch any uh shows
like that i don't know what they've been
saying
but when i say that if joe biden is
president
he would be the president with the most
progressive policy in american history
the most progressive platform in
american history it's not a meaningless
statement
it would literally be the truth if you
look at taxation
capital gains uncapping social security
taxes at 400 000
you look at clean energy i mean it's
whether he gets it done or not is a fair
question
and that's a fair question of any
candidate um but uh this is the reality
and and we we're going to be covering
that more and very powerfully
very very soon i want to say thanks to
david braver who's new member number two
today at joinpackman.com and shanice
morrison who is new member number three
we're doing something special today we
are including
both website memberships and patreon
in our goal to get we're initially
trying to get to 25.
last debate we got to 338 but we're
trying to get to 25.
it all counts today my friends thank you
uh let's see here desiree dewitt
says mike pence the pious feckless
incumbent
versus kamala his smart pragmatic better
qualified replacement
fingers crossed tonight goes well for
her well said desiree
sunil wani says david can you address
the ramifications of trump's
dexamethasone treatment the crash coming
off this drug could be quite substantial
thanks
yeah so the dexamethasone may be
affecting trump it may
be and will affect trump in two ways not
my opinion i'm not a doctor
but i've spoken to doctors uh about this
uh already
number one dexamethasone like many
steroids can cause mania
euphoria and delusions of grandeur
and with trump trump often has this
manic tendency and he's always
delusional in terms of his
self-importance
um and so when we see trump acting 15
crazier than normal on twitter it could
be the decks there's no question about
it
on the other hand coming down from it
may leave donald trump feeling far worse
trump talking about how great he feels
now
that could be the roid-induced euphoria
so we just don't know but it's certainly
certainly a serious uh very very serious
question
thanks to phased plasma rifle or plasma
some say for gifting a subscription on
twitch i very much appreciate that
uh chakaseki says what do you call mike
pence when he hosts a head-to-head town
hall
on christmas at midnight a mass debater
masturbator that's great that's i like
that that's genius
bae photo says there's zero excuses for
this debate to be anything other than a
layup for
how harris look at the plexiglas let's
hope so let's hope so she should bring
up by the way
that pence was resisting the plexiglas i
think that would be an important thing
to do um
big thank you to kasmir klaus
pamika pamikala i apologize kasmir i'm
doing the best i can
who is new member number four today and
cole
gala or gala as some say
who is new member number five at
joinpackman.com
okay because we're now getting closer to
the start of the debate
let's look at a couple of different
things donald trump first and foremost
has been tweeting
uncontrollably all day
much of it in all caps conspiracies
i'm not even going to insult you guys i
respect you all too much to insult you
by reading some of these tweets
but it is on and on and on 22 minutes
ago 59 minutes ago an hour an hour two
hours four hours
um six hours ago six hours ago
six hours all day all day all day all
day but the one thing i do want to look
at
is this very bizarre video that donald
trump uh published
two hours ago now the reason i'm muting
it right now
is before we listen to what he says i
want you to look at his physical
appearance
where do we even start so his face looks
completely bruised
now is it just that they've gone
overboard
on the orange makeup because trump looks
ill
it's possible now a few people wrote to
me and said david the weird lighting
is because you can tell that he's kind
of standing where
tree branches most likely are blocking
sunlight to parts of his face
and putting very bright light on parts
of his face and that's the explanation
i think it's the opposite i think that
they deliberately put him
under the weird sunlight in order to
plausibly argue that that's what's weird
but i believe trump's face
his right cheekbone looks completely
bruised he looks more orange than ever
and he has seemingly reverse lipstick
his lips look white
and that may be the case because the
rest of his face is so orange
he may cover his lips uh when when he
gets the spray tan
it is a bizarre appearance and i know
that you know we
what is the what is the relevance of
this the relevance is that he is not
doing well
uh it is not you know i personally don't
care if he's purple
as long as he's a good president and
he's not let's now listen to
what he had to say and you'll notice his
voice still
sounding very strange hi perhaps you
recognize me it's your favorite
president
already very weird already very weird
just the first three seconds
and i'm standing in front of the oval
office at the white house
which is always an exciting place to be
i got back
a day ago from walter reed medical
center now you might remember that trump
actually got back two days ago from
walter reed medical center this raises
two questions one that trump doesn't
know what day it is or what time it is
or that this was actually recorded
yesterday that's
both are possibilities spent four days
there and didn't have to i could have
stayed at the white house but the doctor
said because you're president
a day ago from walter reed medical
center i spent four days there he also
didn't spend four days there he was
there on
saturday and sunday and then part of
monday so
so it's it's already very very strange
he has basic facts wrong about time
and didn't have to i could have stayed
at the white house but the doctors said
because you're president
let's do it i said fine you tell me what
to do and i'm going to listen these are
great professionals they've done a
fantastic job and by the way not only at
walter reed all over the country we have
the greatest doctors in the world we
have the greatest nurses
the greatest first responders law
enforcement so his voice sounds
sounds strained and he's mushmouth and
that could be medication could be
breathing issue could be anything
enforcement by the way
incredible firefighters everybody
they're just great we have great people
so now you hear you hear some kind of a
vehicle reversing in the background and
it's like maybe you do another take you
don't include the vehicle reversing
great country but i spent four days
there
and i went in i wasn't feeling so hot
and within a very short period of time
they gave me regeneron it's called
regeneron
and other things too but i think this
was the key but they gave me regeneron
and it was like unbelievable i
felt good immediately i felt as good
three days ago as i do now
so i just want to say we have regeneron
we have a very similar
drug from eli lilly and they're coming
out and we're trying to get them
on an emergency basis we've uh so this
seems like a trump who has no idea he he
really seems like he's not doing well
it's
this is a totally different trump he
seems barely connected to what he's
saying
authorized it i've authorized it and if
you're in the hospital and you're
feeling really bad
i think we're going to work it so that
you get them and you're going to get
them free and especially if you're a
senior we're going to get you in there
quick
so this seems crazy because at last
count i thought that only 10 people had
received this antibody cocktail from
regeneron it's not even approved
trump's now talking about just giving it
out for free i mean maybe
but it just seems very unlikely we have
hundreds of thousands of doses that are
just about ready
i have emergency use authorization
all set and we got to get it signed now
and you're going to get better you're
going to get better really fast this is
things that nobody even thought of
a few months ago the job that the
scientists the labs everybody have done
is incredible in addition to that you
have various other
drugs that help a lot but these i view
these and now they call them therapeutic
but to me it wasn't therapeutic it just
made me better oh okay
i call that a well that's i mean yeah
okay i'm not even going to go into that
pure so i want to get these things done
so we have to get them done we have to
get them approved i want to get them to
the hospitals where people are feeling
badly
it's much more important to me than the
vaccine but on the vaccines we have many
companies
that are in final stages for the
vaccines johnson johnson moderna
pfizer all great companies many of them
and we're going to have a great vaccine
very very shortly i think we should have
it before the election but frankly the
politics gets involved and that's okay
you know it's impossible to know people
in the twitch chat are making a good
point
it's unclear if trump is speaking this
way because of the things he's on
or because he's off of stuff and this is
sick trump like i have no idea honestly
i have no clue
they want to play their games it's going
to be right after the election
but we did it nobody else nobody else
would have been able to do it
the fda has acted as quickly as
they've ever acted in history there's
never been a time and no president's
ever pushed him like i pushed him either
to be honest with you
all right but the fda is approving
things in
a matter of weeks it used to take a
matter of years
so we have these drugs eli lilly okay
hold on people are saying at 150 he
coughs let me check that out and then
we'll go back up to the three-minute
mark
a few months ago the job that the
scientists the labs
everybody have done is incredible in
addition to that you have
various other oh i didn't even notice
the cut oh my god that i
i was looking at chat when that happened
that's a crazy jump yeah
so clearly he must have had a coughing
fit or something like that uh okay let's
let's watch just a little bit more
a short 24 hours later i was feeling
great i want to get out of the hospital
and that's what i want for everybody i
want everybody
to be given the same treatment as your
president right
well not everybody's going to get a
six-room suite at walter reed or a
helicopter ride unfortunately many
people are
going to get nothing unfortunately i
feel great i feel like
perfect so i think this was a blessing
from god that i caught it
there it was a blessing in disguise i
caught it
i heard about this drug i said let me
take it it was my suggestion i said let
me take it
and it was incredible the way it worked
incredible
and i think if i didn't catch it would
be looking at that like a number of
other drugs but
it really did a fantastic job i want to
get for you
what i got okay so anyway this is
clearly you know i mean it's it's not
going very well as you all
as you all can tell and just an incredi
no hydroxy by the way he did not receive
hydroxy as many of you know but
trump doesn't look good he doesn't look
good okay
a few other oh wait hold on let me get
caught up here if you're just joining us
we're
15 minutes from the start of the debate
glad you're with me uh wesley radburn is
new member number six today
steven jessup is number seven rebecca
eisner is number eight
dag makara is number nine jennifer gasly
is new member number 10
stella archer is number 11.
melissa green is number 12 thomas
voorhees
is number 13 ellen jones is 14
jason mckinnon is number 15 and betty
morgan via patreon
uh patreon also known as is number 16
which i very much uh appreciate that
thank you very much
oh i have people asked yeah i got so two
different
actually let's do this next okay couple
different things we had some great
media elements since the last debate
okay these are all on my instagram you
should be following me on instagram at
david.pakman if you're not
i don't know how you get through the day
to be perfectly frank but
we got a great piece in the wrap a few
days ago
rise of indie news creators less than
half of youtube's most watched news
channels
tied to legacy brands excellent
excellent article
and then this i think the twitch chat
will appreciate this
uh there was an article in none other
than the new york times
um written about my
and other coverage of the debate on
twitch and this is the the the part
about me this is so great
nearly 52 000 of those people follow
david pakman it's now 53 000 on twitch
by the way don't don't don't
i don't want to pretend i don't want to
disappear a thousand of you it's now 53
but it was 52 last week
who had a relatively restrained approach
to covering the debate on twitch i think
that is like
half the debate i was like this that's i
think what they mean
mostly he listened as the candidates
shouted over each other
shortly before 10 pm with more than half
an hour left
he seemed ready to give up this is the
downfall of american democracy people he
said
i really should turn it off this is sad
that that is an emblematic quote from uh
from from my coverage of last week's
debate that's absolutely true but the
point is
thanks to the people watching on twitch
uh i very much appreciate it and uh we
are at 53
000 onward and upward people asking
about this video
this is also on my instagram this is
just video of me juking out some puppies
check this out
boom boom okay so i do one juke but then
here's the big one look at that fancy
footwork and the dogs just run into each
other and i'm gone
look at that i actually got a call from
belichick after this
asking if i could work with some of the
running backs and i said
you got bigger pri i've got bigger fish
to fry we're trying to get trump out but
that
i mean the dogs just collapsed unable to
cover me there
and then uh you know one of them able to
sort of come back
but they they didn't they didn't stand a
chance
there it is boom boom boom and then gone
just before they know it i'm 50 yards
away there's just no way to stop
anyway follow me on instagram for stuff
like that uh daviddavid.pakman on
instagram
uh okay very good and then oh so here's
the last thing i was going to mention
before we get back to your messages and
other things
um during the last debate
we gained on youtube 6 6846 youtube
subscribers that's 68.46
68.46 incredible just our best stream
ever
last tuesday and i don't know how we
will do today we will see
my instinct is there's typically less
interest in the vp debates
the counter would be with everything
going on with uh captain covid and half
the white house having the coronavirus
and all of that stuff
um maybe there will be more interest we
just don't know
we really just don't know okay
um other super chats that are coming in
let's do a couple of super chats
uh david have you addressed your
egregious clickbait the other day on
twitter
trump collapses okay so let me address
that
last tuesday we did a video about a
press conference that trump did
and we titled the video trump collapses
at disgusting press briefing or
something like that
then trump got coronavirus but that
video didn't publish until saturday we
had forgotten about it because it was a
tuesday video
the video publishes with the title trump
collapses at press briefing
and people said david he has coronavirus
you know now collapses
people are going to think you mean it
literally not metaphorically i
immediately felt bad about it we made a
mistake i
instantly changed it oh what's going on
okay it's about to start
um i instantly changed it to trump
implodes i assumed nobody would take
implodes literally and um we that
you guys were right on that you guys
were completely right on that
um okay very powerful um this is what we
call the max out
super chat matt wilson with a 500 super
chat matt i can't thank you enough
matt says thank you for keeping me sane
if some long time red states go blue
does that lend any credence to
accelerationist ideas
uh no i don't think so i personally
dislike the view and am horrified by the
last four years
p.s a combination show and bonus show
format would be great
so i don't have to pull over to change
it up that would be helpful wow
matt i am going to personally look into
that for you
although in the past people tend to have
not liked that not like that idea
i'm going to look into that for you more
than very strongly i appreciate the
support very very much
okay a couple other things there is new
polling that
is disastrous for donald trump okay
we have uh out of uh look at this
arizona biden plus two wisconsin biden
plus five
ohio biden plus one pennsylvania biden
plus five pennsylvania
biden plus thirteen florida biden up
four and eleven iowa five
nevada six west virginia trump 18
the west virginia numbers are terrible
let me explain why
in 2016 trump won virginia by 40 west
virginia by 42.
if trump only wins vet west virginia by
18
it would be very bad for him four more
general election polls fox says biden
plus 10
biden uh plus nine according to
economist
biden plus 12 according to reuters
and biden plus 12 according to rasmussen
which often has
um the the best numbers for trump so
really bad
what does this mean for us nothing
nothing nothing it means you only have
there's a hair on my microphone there we
go
um who's it my hair is not that long
that's weird uh
it means nothing other than you
absolutely
must must must vote that is all that we
have to do
okay what else do we have going on here
uh oh okay i have a new debut song for
you
this is the original hit debuted on my
channel
from joseph woodward this is plasma the
song of the summer just as a reminder
to make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
beautiful
convalescent
[Music]
that when raves come back after
coronavirus that is going to be the song
that people are going to be going
bonkers with light sticks and ecstasy
too so that's crazy
now i have a new release we are just
moments from the vp debate i have a new
fresh track from uh
from joe woodward you can see it even
has a great oh wait hold on i can't even
show it to you that doesn't work
uh we even have a great wait can i do it
this way
there it is the an accompanying image
here of donald trump i guess this is
when donald trump did wwe this is called
don't be afraid of it
this is definitely lower key this is not
as much of a pump
up track but i think it's beautifully
done
world premiere ladies and gentlemen
world premiere of don't be afraid of it
take a look nobody that's a leader would
not do what i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in coronavirus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
felt great like better than i have in a
long time
be afraid wow i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world you're
afraid of it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
beautiful but don't let it dominate your
lives get out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and they're all happy okay it's so good
i mean joseph woodward is really a
national treasure and i've encouraged
joseph to
keep it going because those are some
really really powerful tracks and at
some point i could even see doing a uh
so yeah i do want to i do want to do the
drum track myself to something
i'm still working on getting all of that
set up properly i'm having a technical
issue still
but i would even contribute it would be
interesting to do a track that
mixes my uh something i say on the show
audio samples of me with audio samples
of trump anyway
it's stunning i mean just really really
great great material
okay we are four minutes from the start
of this debate
i want to remind you and this is this is
i'm making a plea
a plea for support this program
primarily
is supported by memberships at
joinpacman.com
okay if you hate me forget about it
if you think what i do is worthless get
the hell out of here or stay but don't
send me a penny i don't want a penny i
don't want a dime i don't want a nickel
or a quarter or a half dollar or any of
it
if you sort of like what we do here and
you think it's worth
something consider getting a membership
at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code right above
me which expires on election day
sorry i froze there it expires on
election day 2020 now is the coupon code
you save 66 percent everybody is pleased
and we will continue filling up this
blue bar
but we have quadrupled the website
resources
at joinpakman.com to be able to handle
the traffic we
hope not expect hope will
hammer the website today and the last
debate we had 338 people sign up
let's do it let's do it and let's listen
to what's going on here bounce the two
candidates onto stage they'll come on
the stage simultaneously
that'll be a time to applaud and then
applaud again at the very end of the
debate
but if you could if you could keep uh
restrain your
enthusiasm between those two times i'd
appreciate it
and if you could send me a little good
karma that would also be appreciated
but quietly i'm going now to
sit down and get settled and turn my
back to you but not in a rude way
and i'll see you on the other side
thanks again for being here
all right so a lot of very powerful and
important admonishments coming forward
here we are standing by
for the start of this debate uh just
have a couple of streams going at once
always want to be very very well
prepared
to have the best stream possible for you
guys and
uh we are getting very very close let's
see if we can get a couple of other
super chats in
before things start uh ramsay asks
whether trump is trapped in a social
media echo chamber
by and large yeah uh what's up my homies
says your twitch plugin just says
subscribers i just fixed it yeah i don't
know why it moves throughout the day but
uh
1271 from the standpoint of twitch
we love it uh what else do we have here
stephanie berg says play that music
during the debate in the background it
is a great track it is
really really a great track um
ldinerproductions asks if i'm concerned
about a possible bush gore scenario in
2020 how do we prevent this and ensure
states are not called early before
mail-in votes are counted
everybody knows to expect the mail-in
ballots so i don't think
it the concern is it might take too long
to get the results that's the concern uh
okay i'm seeing new members come in
michael como and uh paul pennington
and others i am going to keep tabs on
the exact number
as the debate gets going i want to spend
as much time now with your messages but
i'm seeing
every single one of those new
memberships i appreciate it
and um remember before we do get started
hit that subscribe button for me on
youtube hit that follow button on twitch
i mentioned earlier last debate
6846 people
um added subscriptions on youtube
which is crazy it's crazy
and uh we want to do as best we can
today
as well ryan says they're calling me a
super spreader no other president has
been as tremendous at spreading kovid as
your favorite president
sean tedrow loves the high energy today
you're making me and my soon-to-be wife
crack
up yeah covet weddings wedding wedding
uh phase wedding uh during covet phase
has been weird
i'm scheduled to go to a wedding in
italy in a year
actually in 11 months you guys think
it'll happen i don't know
i hope it does i'd love to be i would
love nothing more than to be in italy
sipping cappuccino in 11 months thanks
to aunt
fufu for subscribing with twitch prime
crow has subscribed and says i actually
really love the joe woodward track the
beat is seriously fire
absolutely it's an it's an incredible
track we're going to revisit it after
the debate for sure
um thanks also to smoove lifey
who has subscribed on twitch john
jarabek says david thank you for all the
amazing content and level-headedness
i've been a daily follower for four
years
seeing your recent influx of new subs
gives me a hair of hope for the future
keep up the vibes thank you it's all
because of you guys i appreciate it
eric says hey david thanks for all the
live coverage i watch your videos almost
every day it's nice to have a news
source
outside of cnn msnbc sending
positive vibes from canada thank you
i really appreciate that we are going to
keep super chats up
the entire debate so if you have
something you want to communicate to the
um
30 000 people wow that are watching
right now
please please please by all means
go ahead and send that in we are also
starting a stream on facebook right now
and we will see if anybody ends up
joining us on facebook
we are just moments from the start of
the debate interrupting biden and the
moderator
both the pence and harris camp say they
have tested negative for covid
but because of the president's diagnosis
additional
social distancing rules have been
instituted for this debate
at the request of the biden harris
campaign plexa glass barriers have been
placed between the candidates
who will be seated tonight's moderator
is susan page of
usa today i'm in our newshour studio our
reporters and analysts all right so
we're getting very very close to the
start of this as you can see the tension
is building
incredibly we'll keep an eye on what's
going on
live live live in the room twz wants to
know if i like orange pop you know i
haven't had a soda
other than when i was in spain or mexico
and had
real coke sweetened with sugar other
than those
few cokes i have not had a soda in
probably a decade
so i am i'm not well positioned to
comment on uh orange pop
at this point in time and i think that i
actually respect when somebody
doesn't know about something say you're
not the right person to comment i don't
think there's anything wrong with that i
don't know
at this point i've been out of the soda
game for so long i really
could not could not intelligently
comment about that
mark saxon says thanks for your debate
streams makes them way more entertaining
that's why i'm here and to fact check
and to fact check both very very
important
uh no i i am not for lack of a better
term i have not been
sodapoppin that is true people
accurately uh
understanding that david will you please
exclaim let's get ready to rumble just
before the debate starts no
no uh one of the buffer brothers i think
it's br is it bruce or michael buffer
i don't remember which is which i
believe holds copyright to that and
since this we are not a non-profit i
need to be very very careful
uh as far as that goes so i'm i'm not
going to be doing that in any kind of
performative way that would not be good
um yes people pointing out we have
surpassed
the 30 000 viewer mark
on youtube and wondering what what's the
target so
our peak concurrent during the debate
number one was 64 000
across all platforms 64 000.
right now we're at 31 32 34
and it is starting utah and salt lake
city welcome to the first and
only vice presidential debate of 2020.
sponsored by the nonpartisan commission
on presidential debates
wow i'm susan page of usa today
it is my honor to moderate this debate
an important part
of our democracy in kingsbury hall
tonight we have a small
and socially distant audience and we've
taken extra precautions during this
pandemic
among other things everyone in the
audience is required to wear a face mask
and the candidates will be seated 12
feet apart
the audience is enthusiastic about their
candidates but they've agreed to express
that enthusiasm
only twice at the end of the debate and
now
when i introduce the candidates please
welcome california senator kamala harris
and vice president mike pence here we go
ladies and gentlemen
the one and only vice presidential
debate oh my god
oh my god
thank you
wow here we go guys here we go
[Applause]
senator harris and vice president pence
thank you for being here
we're meeting as president trump and the
first lady continue to undergo treatment
in washington
after testing positive for covet 19. we
send our thoughts and prayers to them
for their rapid and complete recovery
for the recovery of everyone afflicted
by the coronavirus
the two campaigns and the commission on
presidential debates have agreed to the
ground rules for tonight
i'm here to enforce them yes on behalf
of the millions of americans who are
watching
one note no one in either campaign or at
the commission
or anywhere else has been told in
advance what topics all raise
or what questions i'll ask love it this
90-minute debate will be divided into
nine
segments of about 10 minutes each i'll
begin a segment by posing a question
to each of you sometimes the same
question sometimes a different question
on the same topic you will then have two
minutes to answer
without interruption by me or the other
candidate
right then we'll take six minutes or so
to discuss the issue
love it at that point although there
will always be more to say we'll move on
to the next topic
we want a debate that is lively but
americans also
deserve a discussion that is civil
these are tumultuous times but we can
and will
have a respectful exchange about the big
issues
facing our nation see that look guys
that was weird let's begin with the
ongoing pandemic
that has cost our country so much
senator harris the coronavirus is not
under control
over the past week johns hopkins reports
that
39 states have had more covet cases over
the past seven days
than in the week before nine states have
set new records
even if a vaccine is released soon the
next administration will face
hard choices what would a biden
administration do in january and
february
that a trump administration wouldn't do
would you impose
new lockdowns for businesses in schools
and hot spots
a federal mandate to wear masks you have
two minutes to respond
without interruption thank you susan
well the american people have witnessed
what is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country here we go
and here are the facts 210 000 dead
people in our country
in just the last several months over 7
million people who have contracted this
disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months wow had
to file for unemployment
the global here's the thing on january
28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people and
that
it would be contracted because it is
airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you oh my god can you imagine if you
knew on january 28th
as opposed to march 13th what they knew
what you might have done to prepare
they knew and they covered it up the
president said it was a hoax
they minimized the seriousness of it the
president said
you're on one side of his ledger if you
wear a mask you're on the other side of
his ledger
if you don't and in spite of all of that
today they still
don't have a plan they still
don't have a plan well joe biden does
she should our plan is about
what we need to do around a national
strategy for contact tracing for testing
for administration of the vaccine and
making sure that it will be free for all
that is the plan that joe biden has and
that i have
knowing that we have to get a hold of
what has been going on
and we need to save our country and joe
biden is the best leader to do that and
frankly this administration has
forfeited thank you their right to
re-election
thank you senator harris but the
attacker vice president pence more than
210
000 americans have died of covid19 since
february
the us death toll as a percentage of our
population
is higher than that of almost every
other wealthy nation
on earth for instance our death rate is
two and a half times that of canada next
door
you head the administration's
coronavirus task force
why is the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy country
beautifully you have two minutes to
respond beautifully interruption
susan thank you and i want to thank the
commission and the university of utah
for
hosting this it appears to have a fat
lip by the way
it's a privilege to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
oh my god but i want the american people
to know
that from the very first day president
donald trump has put the health of
america first no one believes that
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy in
the world
now senator joe biden biden opposed that
decision
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
but i can tell you having led the white
house coronavirus task force that that
decision alone by president trump
bought us invaluable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii and i believe it
saved hundreds of thousands of american
lives
because with that time we were able to
reinvent testing more than 115 million
tests had been done to date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors and
nurses had the resources support they
needed
and when we began really before the
month of february was art to develop a
vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
trump didn't do it under president
trump's leadership operation warp speed
we believe we'll have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way i mean quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
um it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
oh i think the american people know that
this is a president who has put the
health of america first and the american
people i believe with my heart
cut them off can be proud of the
sacrifices they have made
it's safe thank you american life you
couldn't even protect senator harris
would you like to respond absolutely
whatever the vice president is claiming
the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over 210 000
dead bodies in our country american
lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
and you know the vice president is the
head of the task force
right and knew on january 28th how
serious this was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned
that they knew about it and then when
that was exposed
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody i didn't
want to panic anybody he said because
the president wanted people to remain
calm well let's go i don't know but
susan
this is important
and then we'll give the vice president
so i want to ask the american people
how calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how calm were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how kind thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because
you were afraid they could kill them
let's give vice president pence a chance
to respond vice presidents you have one
minute to receive you know there's not a
day gone by that i haven't thought of
every american family that's lost a
loved one
should have thought about him before and
i want all of you to know that you'll
always be in our hearts
yeah and in our prayers but when you say
what the american people have done
over these last eight months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made
the reality if i may if i may finish
that
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told the president in the oval
office the president told the american
people
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
but when you say it hasn't worked when
dr
fauci and dr burks and our medical
experts came to us in the second week of
march
they said if the president didn't take
the unprecedented step
of shutting down roughly half of the
american economy
that we could lose 2.2 million
americans and that's the reality thank
you they also said truth if we did
everything right susan we could still
lose more than 200 000 americans
vice president one life lost is too many
susan
but the american people i believe
deserve credit
for the sacrifices that they have made
putting the health of their family
and their neighbors first our doctors
our nurses our first thank you vice
president pence and i'm going to speak
up on behalf of what the american people
have done vice president pence you were
in the front row
in a rose garden event 11 days ago what
seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now a
cluster of coronavirus cases among those
who were there oh my god
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's safety guidelines
to protect themselves from covid when
you at the white house
have not been doing nasty well the
american people
have demonstrated over the last eight
months
that when given the facts they're
willing to put the health of their
families and their neighbors and people
they don't even know
first president trump and i have great
confidence in
in the american people no it's you we
don't have confidence and their ability
to take that information and put it into
practice
in the height of the epidemic when we
were losing
a heartbreaking number of 2005. to the
white house today
we surged resources to new jersey and
new york
and new orleans and detroit we told the
american people to be done and the
american people made the sacrifices
when the outbreak in the sun belt
happened this summer again americans
stepped forward
but the reality is the work of the
president of the united states goes
on a vacancy on the supreme court of the
united states
uh has come upon us and the president
introduced judge amy coney barrett thank
you
thank you very much that rose wasted the
entire time
done great deal of speculation about it
my wife karen and i were there and
honored to be there
many of the people who were at that
event susan actually were tested for
coronavirus
and it was an outdoor event which all of
our scientists
regularly advise the difference here is
president trump and i trust the american
people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health is
really joe biden and kamala harris
consistently talk about
mandates and not not just mandates with
the coronavirus but
a government takeover of healthcare
thank you thank you green new deal
all government control we're about
freedom and respecting the freedom of
the american people
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth oh my god
you respect the american people when you
have the courage to be a leader
speaking of those things that you may
not want people to hear but they need to
hear so they can protect themselves
but this administration stood on
information that if you had as a
parent if you had as a worker knowing
you didn't have enough money saved up
and now you're standing in a food line
oh my god
because of the ineptitude of an
administration that was unwilling to
speak the truth to the american people
so let's talk about caring about the
american people the american people have
had to sacrifice far too much
because of the incompetence of this
administration it is asking too much of
the people
we're talking about the president asking
too much of the people
that they would not be equipped with the
information they need
to help themselves to protect their
parents and their i'm sorry
uh senator harris i mean i'm sorry
that's fine i'm comma no no you're
senator harris to me
um for life to get back to normal oh my
god dr anthony fauci and other experts
say
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated need to be vaccinated
but half of americans now say they
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was
released now
if the trump administration approves a
vaccine before or after the election
should americans take it and would you
take it
if the public health professionals if dr
fauci if the doctors tell us that we
should take it i'll be the first in line
to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should that we should take it i'm not
taking it
beautiful vice president pence there
have been a lot of repercussions
from this pandemic in recent days the
president's diagnosis of covert 19 has
underscored the importance
of the job that you hold and that you
are seeking
that's our second topic tonight it's the
role of the vice president
i'm giving to kamala one of you will
make history on january 20th
you will be the vice president to the
oldest president the united states has
ever had
donald trump will be 74 years old on
inauguration day
joe biden will be 78 years old that
already has raised concerns among some
voters
concerns that have been sharpened by
president trump's hospitalization
in recent days vice president pence
have you had a conversation or reached
an agreement
with president trump about safeguards or
procedures when it comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not no
do you think you should you have too
many trump health interruptions
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because is he going back the reality is
that we're going to have a vaccine
oh my god in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
he's going back we have five companies
in
phase three clinical trials and we're
right now producing tens of millions of
doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i i just
ask you
stop playing politics with people's
lives
the reality is that we will have a
vaccine we believe
before the end of this year thinking
he's trying to have the
capacity to save countless american
lives and and
your continuous undermining of
confidence in a vaccine is just
it's just unacceptable and let me also
say
you know the reality is when you talk
about about failure in this
administration
we actually do know what failure looks
like in a panoramic
it was 2009 the swine flu arrived in the
united states
that was not the failure thankfully it
was ended up not being as
lethal as the coronavirus
but before the end of the year when joe
biden was vice president of the united
states
not seven and a half million people
contracted the swine flu
60 million americans come how many died
if the swine flu had been as lethal as
the coronavirus the point is it wasn't
that's the it was indistinguishable from
the flu
in practice in lives his own chief of
staff ron claine
would say last year that it was pure
luck
that they did quote everything possible
wrong
and and we learned from that oh my god
they left the strategic national
stockpile
empty that's untrue an empty and hollow
plan but
we still learn from it and i i think the
american people
i'm going to see again vice president
pence i'm sorry we have done
and senator please thank you stop
undermining confidence in a vaccine
senator harris let me ask you the same
question that i asked yeah maybe
have you had a conversation or reached
an agreement with vice president biden
about safeguards or procedures when it
comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
and if you win the election next month
do you think you should you have two
minutes uninterrupted
so let me tell you first of all um the
day i got the call from
from joe biden it was actually a zoom
call
asking me to serve with him on this
ticket was probably one of the most
memorable day but memorable days of my
life um
i you know i thought about my mother
who came to the united states at the age
of 19.
gave birth to me at the age of 25 at
kaiser hospital in oakland california
and the thought that i'd be sitting here
right now
i know would make her proud and she must
be looking down on this
um you know joe and i were raised in a
very similar way
we were raised with values that are
about hard work
about the value and the dignity of
public service
yeah trump and about the importance of
fighting for the dignity of all people
and i think joe asked me to serve with
him because
you know i have a career that included
being elected the first woman district
attorney
of san francisco where i created models
of
innovation for for law enforcement in
terms of reform of the criminal justice
system i was elected
the first woman of color and black woman
to be elected attorney general of the
state of california where i ran
the second largest department of justice
in the united states second only to the
united states department of justice
and there i took on everything from
transnational criminal organizations
to the big banks that were taking
advantage of homeowners you should
answer
the colleges that were taking advantage
of veterans
and then of course now i serve in the
united states senate is only the second
black woman ever elected
to the united states senate i serve on
the senate intelligence committee where
i've been in
regular receipt of classified
information about
threats to our nation and hot spots
around the world i've traveled the world
i've met
with our soldiers in our in war zones
and i think joe has asked me to serve
with him because he knows that we share
we share a purpose which is about
lifting up the american people
and after the four years that we have
seen of donald trump
unifying our country around our common
values
and principles thank you senator harris
you know neither neither
president trump nor vice president biden
has released a sort of detailed
health information that had become the
modern norm
until the 2016 election and in recent
days president trump's doctors have
given
misleading answers or refused to answer
basic questions about his health
and my question to each of you in turn
is is this
information voters deserve
to know vice president pence would you
like to go first
well susan thank you and
let me let me say on behalf of the
president
and the first lady how moved we've all
been
by the outpouring of prayers and concern
this guy's for the president oh my god
and i do believe it's emblematic of the
prayers and
the concern that have ushered forth for
every american impacted
by the coronal virus but the care the
president received
at walter reed hospital the white house
doctors was exceptional not the question
and the transparency that they practiced
all along the way will continue
the american people have a right to know
about the health and well-being
of their president and we'll continue to
do that
but i'm just extremely grateful and was
more than more than a little moved by
the broad and bipartisan support and
senator i want to thank you and joe
biden for your expressions and genuine
concern
and i also want to congratulate you uh
as i did on that phone call
on the historic nature of your
nomination what was the question
i never expected to be on this stage
four years ago so
i know the feeling but um the reality is
uh four years ago he didn't expect to be
here i guess he assumed something would
have happened to him between then and
now
and the stakes have never been higher
because i think the choices have never
been i want to give
senator harris a chance to respond to
the same question i ask which is do
voters
have a right to know more detailed
health information
about presidential candidates and
especially about presidents
especially when they're facing some kind
of challenge absolutely and that's why
joe biden has been
so incredibly transparent and certainly
by contrast
um the president has not um both in
terms of
health records but also let's look at
taxes um we now know because of
great investigative journalism that
donald trump paid
750 dollars you're not going to answer
this is a better way not to answer
i i literally said you mean 750 000
and it was like no seven hundred and
fifty dollars
we now know donald trump owes
and is in debt for 400 million dollars
and just so everyone is clear when when
we say
in debt it means you owe money to
somebody right
and it'd be really good to know who the
president of the united states the
commander-in-chief
owes money to because the american
people have a right to know
what is influencing the president's
decisions
and is he making those decisions on the
best interest of the american people of
you
or self-interest so susan i'm glad you
asked about transparency
because it has to be across the board
joe has been incredibly transparent
over many many years the one thing we
all know about joe
he puts it all out there he he is honest
he is
forthright but donald trump on the other
hand
has been about covering up everything
thanks thank you senator harris i want
to give you a chance to respond
vice president well look i i respect the
fact that joe biden spent 47 years in
public life
i respect your public service as well
thank you
the american people have a president who
was a businessman it's a job creator
failed who's paid tens of millions of
dollars in taxes
payroll taxes property taxes he's
created tens of thousands of american
jobs
and the president said those public
reports are not accurate and
the president's also released literally
stacks of financial disclosures the
american people can
review just as the law allows but the
distinction here is that
joe biden 47 years in public service
compared to president donald trump
who brought all of that experience four
years ago thank you very much
turned this economy around by cutting
taxes rolling back regulation thank you
thank you energy fighting for free and
fair trade
and all that thank you vice president
joe biden mike and kamal harris you know
that's a good segue into our third topic
which is about the economy this has been
another
aspect of life for americans it's been
so affected
by this coronavirus we have a jobs
crisis
brewing on friday we learned that the
unemployment rate had declined to 7.9
percent in september
but the job growth had stalled and that
was before the latest round of layoffs
and furloughs
in the airline industry at disney and
elsewhere hundreds of thousands of
discouraged workers have stopped looking
for work
nearly 11 million jobs that existed at
the beginning of the year
haven't been replaced those hardest hit
include latinos
blacks and women senator harris the
biden harris
campaign has proposed new programs to
boost the economy and you would pay for
that
new spending by raising four trillion
dollars
in taxes on wealthy individuals and
corporations
some economists warn that could curb
entrepreneurial ventures
that fuel growth and create jobs would
raising taxes
put the recovery at risk and you have
two minutes to answer
uninterrupted thank you let's pay
attention
on the issue of the economy i think
there couldn't be a more fundamental
difference
between donald trump and joe biden
joe biden believes you measured the
health and the strength of america's
economy
based on the health and the strength of
the american worker
and the american family on the other
hand you have donald trump
who measures the strength of the economy
based on how rich people are doing
which is why he passed a tax bill not
even benefiting the top one percent
and the biggest corporations of america
leading to
a two trillion dollar deficit that the
american people are going to have to pay
for
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill
he'll get rid of it and what he'll do
with the money is invest it in the
american people
and through a plan that is about
investing in infrastructure something
that donald trump said he would do i
remember hearing about some
infrastructure week i don't think it
ever happened infrastructure joe biden
will do that he'll invest in
infrastructure it's about upgrading our
roads and bridges but also
investing in clean energy and renewable
energy joe is going to invest
that money in what we need to do around
innovation
there was a time when our country
believed in science
and invested in research and development
he wasn't so that we were an
innovation leader on the globe joe biden
will use that money to invest in
education
so for example for folks who want to go
to a two-year community college it will
be free
if you come from a family that makes
less than 125 000
you'll go to a public university for
free
and across the board will make sure that
if you have student loan debt it's cut
by ten thousand dollars
that's how joe biden thinks about the
economy which is it's about
investing in the people of our country
as opposed to passing a tax bill
which had the benefit of letting
american corporations
go offshore to do their business true
thank you senator harris vice president
pence your administration has been
predicting a rapid and robust
recovery but the latest economic report
suggests that's not happening
should americans be braced for an
economic comeback that is going to take
not months but a year
or more you have two minutes to answer
an interrupt more than a year
when president trump and i took office
oh god america had gone through the
slowest economic recovery since the
great depression no no when joe biden
was vice president they tried to tax
and spend and regulate and bail our way
back to a growing economy does anyone
believe president trump cut taxes
across the board despite what senator
harris says
the average american family of four had
two thousand dollars in savings in taxes
and with the rise in wages that occurred
what is it most predominantly for blue
collar hard-working americans
the average household income for a
family of four increased by
thousand dollars following president
trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's going to raise your taxes
untrue it's really remarkable to things
a time where we're going through a
pandemic that lost 22 million jobs at
the height
we've already added back 11.6 million
jobs
because we had a president who cut taxes
rolled back regulation
unleashed american energy fought for
free and fair trade and secured four
trillion dollars from the congress of
the united states to give direct
payments to families
save 50 million jobs through the
paycheck protection program
we literally have spared no expense to
help the american people in the american
worker through this
joe biden and kamala harris want to
raise taxes
they want to bury our economy under a
two trillion dollar green new deal
you make which you were one of the
original co-sponsors of in the united
states senate
they want to abolish fossil fuels and
ban
fracking which would cost hundreds of
thousands of american jobs all across
the heartland
and joe biden wants to go back to the
economic surrender to china that when we
took office
half of our international trade deficit
was with china alone
and joe biden wants to repeal all of the
tariffs that president trump put into
effect to fight for american jobs and
american workers oh you got to get rid
of joe biden says democracy's on the
ballot
make no mistake about it susan the
american economy the american comeback
is on
the ballot with four more years of
growth thank you
opportunity nobody believes it's looking
like mike pence has not only a fat lip
but a black eye it's actually even
weirder than i thought
in the history of this country thank you
vice president pence senator harris
well i mean i that we saw enough of it
in last week's debate but i think this
is supposed to be a debate based on fact
and truth and the truth and the fact is
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than
hundred thousand a year appeal the trump
tax cut mr vice president i'm speaking
excuse me mike speaking be important if
you said the truth
joe biden said twice in the debate last
week that he's going to repeal the trump
tax cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family oh she's
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year
senator that is absolutely not true that
is he only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me
finish we can then have a conversation
okay please
okay oh god joe biden will not raise
taxes on anyone who makes less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year he has
been very clear about that
joe biden will not end fracking he has
been very clear about that
unfortunately joe biden
is the one who during the the great
recession
was responsible for the recovery act
that brought america back and now the
trump pence administration wants to take
credit
when they ran when they rode the
coattails of joe biden's success
for the economy that they had at the
beginning of their term of course now
the economy is a complete disaster
but joe biden on the one hand did that
on the other hand you have donald trump
who has reigned over a recession
that is being compared to the great
depression on the one hand you have joe
biden
who was responsible with president
barack obama
for the affordable care act which
brought health care to over 20
million americans and protected people
with pre-existing conditions and what it
also did
is it saved those families who otherwise
were going bankrupt
because of hospital bills they could not
afford on the other hand
you have donald trump who's in court
right now trying to get rid of
thank you trying to get rid of the
affordable care act
which means that you will lose
protections if you have pre-existing
conditions and i just this is very
important susan yes and it's about we
need to give
we need to get vice president i'd just
like to he interrupted me and i'd like
to just finish
please give her the time if you have a
pre-existing condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're coming for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
of 26 on your parents coverage
they're coming for you senator harris
thank you let me give you a chance to
respond
well i hope we have a chance to talk
about health care because obamacare was
a disaster we're doing right now the
american people remember it well
and president trump and i have a plan to
improve health care
and to protect protect pre-existing
conditions why didn't
you already do it american but look uh
senator harris you're
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the
eye and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee that we will abolish fossil
fuels
i wait we have a two trillion dollar
version of the green new deal susan that
your newspaper usa
today said really wasn't that very
different from the original green new
deal
more taxes more regulation banning
fracking
abolishing fossil fuel crushing american
energy
and economics surrendered china is a
prescription for economic
decline president trump and i will keep
america growing
the v-shaped recovery that's underway
right now
will continue with four more years of
president donald trump thank you very
very
much vice president pence once again
you've provided the perfect segue to a
new topic
which is climate change and vice
president pence i'd like to pose the
first question
to you this year we've seen
record-setting
hurricanes in the south another one
hurricane delta is now threatening the
gulf
and we have seen record-setting
wildfires in the west
do you believe as the scientific
community has concluded
that man-made climate change has made
wildfires
bigger hotter and more deadly and have
made hurricanes wetter
slower and more damaging you have two
minutes uninterrupted
thank you susan well first i'm very
proud of our record on the environment
and on conservation not the question
dude
according to all of the best estimates
are
our air and land are cleaner than any
time ever recorded clean
water is among the cleanest in the world
and just a little while ago the
president signed the outdoors act as the
largest investment in our public lands
and public parks
might as well mute it in 100 years so
president trump has made a commitment to
conservation into the environment
now with regard to climate change the
climate is changing
but the issue is what's the cause
and what do we do about it yeah
president trump has made it clear that
we're going to continue to listen to the
science
now joe biden and kamala harris would
put us back
in the paris climate accord they'd
impose the green new deal
which would crush american energy would
increase the energy costs of america
families in their homes took some
elements and literally would crush
american jobs and president trump and i
believe that
the progress that we have made in a
cleaner environment
has been happening precisely because we
have a strong
free market economy no you know what's
remarkable is
the united states has reduced co2
more than the countries that are still
in the paris climate accord but we've
done it through innovation
and through karate and we've done it
through natural gas
and fracking which senator the american
people can
go look at the record i i know joe biden
says otherwise now as you do but the
both of you repeatedly committed to
abolishing fossil fuel and banning
a fracking and so by creating the kind
of american innovation
we're actually steering toward a
stronger and better environment
with regard to wildfires president trump
and i believe that forest management has
to be frontline
governor gavin newsom from your state
has agreed we've got to work on forest
management
and with regard to hurricanes the
national
oceanic administration tells us that
actually is as difficult as they are
thank you vice president there are no
more hurricanes today than there were a
hundred years ago
thank you but many of the climate alarms
use hurricanes and wildflowers
to try and thank you guys for the goods
of a green new deal
and president trump and i are going to
always put american jobs and american
workers
first senator harris as the vice
president mentioned you co-sponsored the
green new deal
in congress but vice president biden
said in last week's debate
that he does not support the green new
deal but if you look at the biden harris
campaign website it describes the
greener deal as a crucial framework
framework what exactly would be the
stance of a biden harris administration
toward the green new deal you have two
minutes uninterrupted
sure so first of all i will repeat
and the american people know that joe
biden will not
ban fracking that is a fact i wish he
would that is a fact
i will repeat that joe biden has been
very clear
that he thinks about growing jobs which
is why he
will not increase taxes for anyone who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
joe biden's economic plan moody's
which is a reputable wall street firm
has said will create seven million more
jobs
than donald trump's and part of those
jobs that will be created by joe biden
are going to be about clean energy and
renewable energy
because you see joe understands that
the west coast of our country is burning
including my home state of california
joe sees what is happening on the gulf
states
which are being battered by storms joe
has seen and talked with
the farmers in iowa whose entire crops
have been destroyed because of floods
and so joe believes again in science
i'll tell you something susan i served
when i first got to the senate
on the committee that's responsible for
the environment do you know this
administration
took the word science off the website
and then took the phrase climate change
off the website
this we have seen a pattern with this
administration which is they don't
believe in science how can how can
and enjoy this plan it's about saying
we're going to deal with it but we're
also going to create jobs
donald trump when asked about the
wildfires in california
and and the question was you know the
science is telling us this you know what
donald trump said
science doesn't know so
let's talk about who is prepared to lead
our country
over the course of the next four years
on what is an existential threat
to us as human beings joe is about
saying we're going to invest that in
renewable energy
it's going to be about the creation of
millions of jobs we will achieve
net zero emissions by 2050 carbon
neutral by 2035
joe has a plan this has been a lot of
talk from the trump administration and
really it has been to go backward
instead of forward
we will also re-enter the climate
agreement with pride
senator harris just said that climate
change is an existential threat
vice president pence do you believe that
climate change poses an existential
threat
as i said susan the climate is changing
we'll follow the science
but once again uh senator harris
is denying the fact that they're going
to raise taxes
on every american joe biden said twice
in the debate last
week that on day one he was going to
repeal the trump tax cuts
those tax cuts delivered two thousand
dollars in tax relief
to the average family of four across
america and with regard to banning
fracking i just recommend that people
look at the record you yourself said
repeatedly that you would ban fracking
you weren't
an essential co-sponsor of the green new
deal
and while joe biden denied the green new
deal susan thank you for pointing out
the green new deal is on their campaign
website and as usa today said
it's essentially the same plan as you
co-sponsored
with aoc when she submitted it in the
senate and you just heard the senator
say that she's going to resubmit
america to the paris climate accord look
the american people have always
cherished our environment we'll continue
to cherish it we've made great progress
reducing co2 emissions through american
innovation and the development of
natural gas through fracking
we don't need a massive two trillion
dollar green new deal that would impose
all new mandates on american businesses
and american families thank you joe
biden wants us to retrofit
four million thank you vice president
business buildings
it makes no sense it will cost jobs
president trump
thank you very much america first he's
going to put jobs first and we're going
to take
care of our environment and follow the
sciences on the issue of jobs
senator let's talk about that you the
the vice president earlier referred to
as part of what he thinks is an
accomplishment
um the the president's trade war with
china
yeah he said it was great that trade war
you lost it
what ended up happening is because of a
so-called trade war with china
america lost 300 000 manufacturing jobs
farmers have experienced bankruptcy
because of it we are in a manufacturing
recession
because of it and when we look at
where this administration has been there
are estimates that by the end of the
term
of this administration they will have
lost
more jobs than almost any other
presidential
administration and the american people
know what i'm talking about
you know i i think about 20 year olds
you know we have a 20 year old
20 something year old who are coming out
of high school in college right now and
you're wondering
is there going to be a job there for me
we're looking at people who are
trying to figure out how they're going
to pay rent by the end of the month
almost half of american renters are
worried about whether they're going to
be able to pay rent
by the end of the month this is where
the economy is in america right now
and it is because of the catastrophe
and the failure of leadership of this
administration
thank you senator harris pence wearing a
product vice president let me give you
just 15 seconds to respond because then
i want to move on to well i'd love to
respond look
lost the trade war with china joe biden
never fought it
joe biden has been a cheerleader for
communist china through over the last
several decades
jumping and and again senator harris
you're entitled to your opinion you're
not entitled to your own facts
joe biden was vice president we lost 200
000 manufacturing jobs
and president obama said they were never
coming back he said we needed a magic
wand to bring him back
in our first three years after we cut
taxes roll back regulation
unleashed american energy this
administration saw
500 000 manufactures jobs thank you
and that's exactly the kind of growth
we're going to continue to see as we
bring our nation through
thank you very much pandemic the green
new deal your massive new mandate your
paris climate accord
it's going to kill jobs this time just
like it killed jobs i just need to
respond very much
15 seconds thank you thank you
joe biden is responsible for saving
america's auto industry and you voted
against it
so let's set the record straight thank
you
i'd like to talk about china we have as
our next
topic wow we have no more complicated or
consequential
foreign relationship than the one with
china right
it is a huge market for american
agricultural goods it's a
potential partner in dealing with
climate change in north korea
and in a video tonight president trump
again blamed it
for the coronavirus saying china will
pay
vice president pence how would you
describe our
our fundamental relationship with china
competitors
adversaries enemies you have two minutes
thank you susan it'll be about joe biden
well let me before i
leave that let me let me speak to voting
records if i can
you know everybody knows that nafta cost
literally
thousands of american factories we saw
automotive jobs go south of the border
president trump
fought to renegotiate nafta in the
united states mexico
canada agreement is now the law of the
land please american people deserve to
know
senator kamala harris was one of only 10
members of the senate to vote against
the usmca
it was a huge win for american auto
workers it was a huge win
for american farmers especially dairy in
the upper midwest
but senator you you said it didn't go
far enough on climate change
that that you put your your radical
environmental agenda ahead of american
auto workers and ahead of american
what is jobs i think the american people
deserve to know that is probably why
newsweek magazine said that that kamala
harris was the most
liberal member of the united states
senator i wish that were true
more liberal than bernie sanders uh more
more liberal than
any of the others in the united states
senate so
now with regard to china look
susan first and foremost
china is to blame for the corona oh my
god he doesn't know what he's talking
about
and president trump is not happy about
it he's made that very clear made it
clear again today
china and the world health organization
did not play straight with the american
people
they did not let our personnel into
china
to get information on the coronavirus
until the middle of february
fortunately president trump in dealing
with china from the outset of this
administration
standing up to china that had been
taking advantage of america for decades
in the wake of joe biden's cheerleading
for china
president trump made that decision
before the end of january to suspend
all travel from china and again the
american people deserve to know joe
biden
opposed president trump's decision to
suspend all travel
from china he said it was hysterical he
said thank you very much
for president trump china we're going to
continue to stand
strong thank you vice president we want
to improve the relationship but we're
going to
level the playing field and we're going
to hold china accountable for what they
did to america
with the coronavirus thank you senator
harris let me ask you the same
question that i asked the vice president
how would you describe
our fundamental relationship with china
are we competitors
adversaries enemies you'll have two
minutes uninterrupted
susan the trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss of american
lives american jobs
and america's standing
there is a weird obsession that
president trump has had
with getting rid of whatever
accomplishment
was achieved by president obama and vice
president biden
for example they created within the
white house
an office that basically was responsible
for monitoring pandemics
they got away they got rid of it it's
not true
there it is a team of disease
experts that president obama
and vice president biden dispatched to
china
to monitor what is now predictable and
what might happen
they pulled them out we now are looking
at 210 000 americans who have lost their
lives
let's look at the job situation we
mentioned before
the trade deal the trade war they wanted
to call it with china
it resulted in the loss of over 300
manufacturing jobs and a manufacturing
recession
and the american consumer paying
thousands of dollars more for goods
because of that failed war that they
called it
then let's talk about standing pew a
reputable
research firm has done an analysis
that shows that leaders of all of our
formerly allied countries have now
decided
that they hold in greater esteem and
respect xi jinping
the head of the chinese communist party
as well they do donald trump
the president of the united states the
commander-in-chief of the united states
this is where we are today because of a
failure of leadership by this
administration
senator harris we've seen changes in the
in the role of the united states
in terms of global leadership over the
past four years
and of course times do change what's
your definition we've seen strains with
china of course
as the vice president mentioned we've
seen strange with our traditional allies
in nato and elsewhere what is your
definition of the role of american
leadership
in 2020 so
you know joe is i love talking with joe
about a lot of these issues and you know
joe
he i think he said it quite well he says
you know foreign policy it might sound
complicated but really it's
relationships
so just think about it as relationships
and
so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships um
you gotta keep your word to your friends
gotta be loyal to your friends people
who've stood with you
gotta stand with them you gotta know who
your adversaries are
and keep them in check but what we have
seen
with donald trump is that he has
betrayed our friends and it and and be
tr
and and and embraced dictators around
the world
let's take for example russia
so russia i serve on the intelligence
committee
of the united states senate america's
intelligence community told us
russia interfered in the election of the
president of the united states in 2016
and is playing in 2020.
christopher wray the director of the fbi
said the same
but donald trump the commander-in-chief
of the united states of america
prefers to take the word of vladimir
putin over the word of the american
intelligence community
you look at our friends at nato
he has walked away from agreements you
can talk look at the iran nuclear deal
which now has put us in a position
where we are less safe because they are
building up
what might end up being a significant
nuclear
arsenal we were in that deal guys we
were in the
iran nuclear deal with friends with
allies around the country and because of
donald trump's unilateral approach to
foreign policy
coupled with his isolationism he pulled
us out and has made america less safe so
susan
it's about relationships and the thing
that has always been part of the
strength of our nation
in addition to our great military has
been that we keep our word but donald
trump doesn't understand that
because he doesn't understand what it
means to be honest
thank you thank you uh thank you senator
harris vice president
let me give you a chance to respond well
thank you um well president trump kept
his word when we moved the american
embassy to jerusalem which was stupid
capital of the state of israel idiotic
move when joe biden was vice president
they promised to do that and they never
did
we've stood strong with our allies but
we've been demanding
nato is now contributing more to our
common defense than
ever before thanks to president trump's
leadership
we've strengthened our alliances across
the asia pacific
and we've stood strong against those who
would do us harm
you know when president trump came into
office isis had captured an
area of the middle east the size of
pennsylvania but president trump
unleashed the american military and our
armed forces destroyed the isis
caliphate
and took down their leader al-baghdadi
without one american casualty
al baghdadi was uh responsible
for the death of thousands um
but notably america's hearts today are
with the family of kayla mueller
your parents which are here with us
tonight in salt lake city
today two of the isis killers
responsible for kayla mueller's murder
were brought to justice in the united
states
jihadi john was killed on the
battlefield along with the other beetle
the reality is that when joe biden was
vice president we had an opportunity
to save caleb miller breaks my heart to
reflect on him but the military came
into the oval office
presented a plan they said they knew
where caleb was
baghdadi had held her for 18 months
abused her mercilessly before they
killed her but when joe biden was vice
president they hesitated
for a month and when armed forces
finally went in
it was clear she'd been moved two days
earlier and her family
says with a heart that broke the heart
of every american that
if president donald trump had been
president they believe kayla would be
alive today
thank you very soon we destroyed the
isis caliphate
uh you talk about re-entering the iran
nuclear deal i mean the last
administration transferred 1.8 billion
dollars
to the leading state sponsor thank you
very much for terrorism
president donald trump got us out of the
day thank you vice president pence
and when qasim solomonia was traveling
to baghdad thank you very much
harm to americans president donald trump
thank you vice president pence and
america is is safer
our allies are safer and the american
people know president donald trump will
never thank you vice president take
action i would like to give
senator harris a chance to respond but
not at such great length because of
course there are other topics we want to
talk about but i would like equal time
yes thank you please go ahead first of
all to the mueller family i i know
about your daughter's case and i'm so
sorry
i'm so sorry um what happened to her
is awful and it should have never
happened
and i know joe feels the same way and i
know that president obama feels the same
way
um but you mentioned solemnani let's
let's start there
so after the strike on soleimani there
was a counter
strike on our troops in iraq
and they suffered
serious brain injuries and do you know
what donald trump dismissed them as
headaches headaches and this is about a
pattern of donald trump's
where he has referred to our
men who are serving in our military as
suckers and losers
donald trump who went to arlington
cemetery
and stood above the graves
of our fallen heroes
and said what's in it for them
right because of course you know he only
thinks about what's in it
for him let's take what he said about
john mccain
a great american hero
and and donald trump says he doesn't
deserve to be called a hero
because he was a prisoner of war
take and this is this is very important
when you want to talk about
who is the current commander-in-chief
and what they care about and what they
don't care about
public reporting that russia had
bounties on the heads
of american soldiers and you know what a
bounty is
it's somebody puts a price on your head
and they will pay it if you are
killed and donald trump had talked at
least six times
to vladimir putin and never brought up
the subject
joe biden would never do that thank you
joe biden would but
joe biden would hold russia to account
for any threat to our nation's security
or to our troops
who are sacrificing their lives for the
sake of our democracy and our safety
thank you
senator harris this is such an important
issue but we have other important issues
as well
i want to make sure we have a chance i
really have to talk about that you
already went over 90 seconds
she has 15 seconds because well i gotta
go i'm trying to keep learning
i'm sorry but vice president you've had
more time than she's had
so far against president donald trump
slander
regarding men and women of our armed
forces absurd
i'm sorry my son is a captain in the
united states marine corps
my son-in-law is deployed in the united
states navy he's just
i can assure all of you with sons and
daughters serving in our military
president donald trump not only respects
but reveres
all of those who serve in our country
otherwise
it's ridiculous
agreed to the rules for tonight's debate
with the commission on presidential base
i'm here to enforce them which involves
only from one topic
to another giving roughly equal time to
both of you which is what i'm trying
very hard to go right ahead
so i want to go ahead and move to the
next topic which is an important one
as the last topic was and that is the
supreme court
uh oh on monday the senate judiciary
committee is scheduled to open hearings
on amy coney barrett's nomination to the
supreme court senator harris
you'll be there as a member of the
committee her confirmation would cement
the court's conservative majority and
make it likely open to more abortion
restrictions even to overturning the
landmark roe v wade ruling
access to abortion would then be up to
the states
vice president pence you're the former
governor of indiana
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
indiana to do would you want your home
state to ban
all abortions you have two minutes
uninterrupted
well thank you for the question but i'll
use a little bit of my time to respond
to that very important issue before
the american people deserve to know
qasim salamani the iranian general was
responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
when the opportunity came we saw him
headed to baghdad to
kill more americans president trump
didn't hesitate
and qasim salamani is gone but you
deserve to know that joe biden
and kamala harris actually criticized
the decision to take out solomon
qasim salamani it's really inexplicable
but
with regard to joe biden it's
explainable
because history records that joe biden
actually opposed the raid against osama
bin laden
it's absolutely essential that we have a
commander-in-chief
who will not hesitate to act to protect
american lives
and to protect american service members
and that's what you have in president
donald trump
now with regard to the supreme court of
the united states
right let me say president trump and i
could not be more enthusiastic was about
abortion in india about the opportunity
to see judge amy coney barrett
become justice amy coney barrett she's a
brilliant woman
and she will bring a lifetime of
experience and a sizable american family
to the supreme court of the united
states and our hope is in the hearing
next week
unlike justice kavanaugh received with
treatment from you and others
i'd like to see pence answer questions
from the biden trump debate from last
week actually
the tax on her christian faith that we
saw before
i mean the democrat chairman of the
judiciary committee before
when when judge barrett was being
confirmed for the court of appeals
expressed concern that
the dogma of her faith lived loudly in
her
dick durbin of illinois said that it was
a concern
senator i know one of our judicial
nominees you actually
attacked because they remember the
catholic knights of columbus
just because the knights of columbus
holds pro-life views thank you
thank you thank you vice president thank
you for your time where the hearing
takes place
thank you vice president judge amy
connor will be respected
senator harris you're the senator from
and former attorney general of
california so let me ask you a parallel
question to the one i posed to the vice
president
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
california to do would you want your
home state to enact no restrictions on
access to abortion
and you have two minutes uninterrupted
thank you
susan first of all joe biden and i are
both people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith and in fact
joe
if elected will be only the second
practicing catholic as president of the
united states the religious candidate
i'm on the issue of this of this
nomination
joe and i are very clear as are the
majority of the american people
we are 27 days before the decision about
who will
be the next president of the united
states and you know before
when this conversation has come up you
know it's been about election year or
election time
we're literally in an election
over four million people have voted
people are in the process of voting
right now
and so joe has been very clear as the
american people are
let the american people fill that seat
in the white house
and then we'll fill that seat on the
united states supreme court
to your point susan the issues before us
couldn't be more serious there's the
issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her
own body it should be her decision and
not that of donald trump
and the vice president michael pence but
let's also look at what else is before
the
the court it's the affordable care act
like
literally in the midst of a public
health pandemic
when over and 210 thousand people have
died
and seven million people probably have
what will be in the future considered a
pre-existing condition because you
you contracted the virus donald trump is
in court right now trying to get rid of
the affordable care act and i said it
before
and it bears repeating this means
that there will be no more protections
if they win
for people with pre-existing conditions
this
means that over 20 million people will
lose your coverage
it means that if you're under the age of
26 you can't stay on your parents
coverage anymore
and here's the thing the contrast
couldn't be more clear
they're trying to get rid of the
affordable care act joe biden is saying
let's expand coverage
let's give you a choice of a public
option or private coverage
let's bring down premiums let's lower
medicare eligibility to 60.
thank you senator that's true leadership
you know you mentioned
uh earlier vice president pence that the
president was committed
to maintaining protections for people
with pre-existing conditions
um and but you do have this court case
that you are supporting your
administration supporting
that would strike down the affordable
care act the president
says president trump says that he's
going to protect people conjunctivitis
is sometimes uh coinciding with covid i
i just am letting people know that
the toughest nuts to crack when they
were passing the affordable care act so
tell us specifically how would your
administration
protect americans with pre-existing
conditions have access to affordable
insurance
if the affordable care act is struck
down
well thank you susan but let me just say
addressing your very first question
let's go back to the first question from
an hour and ten minutes ago a president
who stands without apology for the
sanctity of human life
i'm pro-life i i don't apologize for it
you should
and this is another one of those cases
where there's such a dramatic
contrast joe biden and kamala harris
support
taxpayer funding of abortion all the way
up to the moment of birth
late term abortion they want to increase
funding to planned parenthood
of america now for our part i i would
never presume how judge amy coney
barrett
would rule on the supreme court of the
united states but
will continue to stand strong for the
right to life when you speak about
the supreme court though i think the
american people really deserve an answer
senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett is
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court what
is wrong which has had nine seats for
150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
the supreme court to get your way i'm so
glad we went through a little history
lesson let's do that a little more
please in 1816 i'd like you to answer
the question
anyone else i'm speaking okay thanks
mike
in 1864 one of the
i think political heroes certainly of
the president i assume if you
also mr vice president is abraham
lincoln
abraham lincoln was up for re-election
oh my god
and it was 27 days before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate
different party at the time but honest
abe
said it's not the right thing to do the
american people
deserve to make the decision about who
will be the next president of the united
states
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our land and so
joe and i are very clear
the american people are voting right now
and it should be their decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime thank you senator
harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court for no reason if
you don't get your way in this
nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave it
anonymous trying to answer you
american people deserve a straight
answer and and if you haven't figured it
out yet the straight answer is they are
going to
pack the supreme court maybe they will
somehow do this
i got to tell you people across this
country if you cherish our supreme court
and then if you cherish the separation
of powers you need to reject
the biden harris ticket come november
the 3rd re-elect president donald trump
and we'll stand by that separation
powers in a nine-seat supreme court yeah
let's talk about pac and the court then
let's talk about that yeah i'm about to
so the trump pence administration
has been because i sit on the senate
judiciary committee susan as you
mentioned
and i have witnessed the appointments
for lifetime appointments to the
federal courts district courts courts of
appeal
people who are purely ideological people
who have been reviewed by
by legal professional organizations and
found to have been not competent
are substandard and do you know
that of the 50 people who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals for lifetime appointments
not one is black this is what
they've been doing you want to talk
about packing a court let's have that
discussion
all right thank you thank you senator
let's go on and talk about
the issue of racial justice i just want
the record i want to say she never
answered the question
so maybe the next debate joe biden will
answer the question but i think the
american people know the answer thank
you vice president
in march bryony the answer is probably
no if you know joe biden's history on
packing the court just to let you know
after police officers executing a search
warrant in a narcotics investigation
broke into her apartment
the police said they identified
themselves taylor's boyfriend said he
didn't hear them do that
he used a gun registered to him to fire
a shot which wounded an officer
the officers then fired more than 20
rounds into the apartment they say they
were acting
in self-defense none of them have been
indicted
in connection with her death senator
harris
in the case of riona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes i don't believe so
and i've i've talked with
brianna's mother tamika palmer and her
family
and her family deserves justice she was
a beautiful young woman
she had as her life goal to become a
nurse and she wanted to become an emt
to first learn what's going on out on
the street
so she could then become a nurse and
save lives
and her life was taken unjustifiably and
tragically and violently
and it just it brings me to
you know the eight minutes and 46
seconds that america
witnessed during which
an american man was tortured
and killed under the knee
of an armed uniformed police officer
and people around our country of
every race of every age of
every gender perfect strangers to each
other
marched shoulder to shoulder arm and arm
fighting for us to finally achieve that
ideal of equal justice under
law and i was a part of those peaceful
protests
and i believe strong that
first of all we are never going to
condone violence but we
always must fight for
the values that we hold dear including
the fight to achieve our ideals
and that's why joe biden and i have said
on this subject
look and i'm a former career prosecutor
i know what i'm talking about
bad cops are bad for good cops we need
reform
of our policing in america and our
criminal justice system which is why joe
and i
will immediately ban chokeholds and
carotid holes
george floyd would be alive today if we
did that we will
require a national registry for police
officers who break the law
we will on the issue of criminal justice
reform
get rid of private prisons and cash bail
and we will decriminalize marijuana and
we will
be here we will expunge the records of
those who have been convicted
of marijuana this is thank you time for
leadership on a
tragic tragic issue senator harrison
black people in america
thank you senator thank you vice
president pence let me pose the same
question to you
in the case of briona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes uninterrupted
well our heart breaks for the loss of
anything
any innocent american life not the
question the family of brianna taylor
has our sympathies
not the question but i i trust our
justice system
a grand jury that refused the evidence
and it really is remarkable that as a
former prosecutor
you would assume that an impaneled grand
jury looking at all the evidence got it
wrong
but you're entitled to your opinion
senator
i think and with regard to george floyd
there's no excuse for what happened to
george floyd and justice will be served
well but there's also no excuse for the
rioting and
looting that followed i mean it really
is astonishing
flora westbrook is with us here tonight
in salt lake city
just a few weeks ago i stood at what
used to be
her salon was burned to the ground
by rioters and looters and and flora is
still trying to put her life back
together
and i must tell you this this this
presumption
that you hear consistently from joe
biden and kamala harris
that that america is systemically racist
and that as joe biden said that he
believes that law enforcement has an
implicit
bias against minorities
is is a great insult to the men and
women who serve in law enforcement and i
want everyone to know who puts on the
uniform of law enforcement every day
and president trump and i stand with you
and it is remarkable that oh my god when
senator tim scott
tried to pass a police reform bill you
guys see that brought together a group
of republicans and democrats senator
harris
is that a b you got up and walked out of
the room and then you filibustered
senator
tim scott's bill on the senate floor
that would have provided new
accountability new repeat resources
but we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
proving public safety and supporting our
african american
thank you for all of our minorities
under president trump's leadership thank
you very much always stand with law
enforcement and we'll do
what we do thank you your time is the
lives of african americans
thank you very much record investments
in education and the fight for school
choice for all of our money thank you
very much i'd like to respond senator
harris
i will not sit here and be lectured by
the vice president
on what it means to enforce the laws of
our country i am the only one on this
stage
who has personally prosecuted everything
from
child sexual assault to homicide i'm the
only one on the stage was prosecuted the
big banks
for taking advantage of america's
homeowners i'm the only one on this
stage
who prosecuted for-profit colleges for
taking advantage of our veterans
and the reality of this is that we are
talking about an election in 27 days
where last week the president of the
united states took a debate stage in
front of 70 million americans and
refused to condemn
white supremacists it's still there and
it wasn't like he didn't have a chance
he didn't do it and then he doubled down
and then he said when pressed stand back
stand by and
this is a part of a pattern
of donald trump's you he was
he called mexicans rapists and criminals
he instituted as his first act a muslim
ban
he on the issue of charlottesville where
people were
peacefully protesting the need for
racial justice
where a young woman was killed and on
the other side there were neo-nazis
carrying
tiki torches shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs and donald trump when
asked about it said
there were fine people on both sides
this is who we have as the president of
the united states and america you
deserve
better joe biden will be a president who
brings our country together senator
harris
and and recognizes the beauty in our
diversity
and the fact that we all have so much
more in common than what separates us
vice president pence let me give you a
minute to respond thank you susan i
appreciate that very much susan you know
i think this is one of the things that
makes people dislike the media so much
in this country susan
is that you selectively edit just like
senator harris did
comments that president trump and i and
others on our side of the ahmed
i mean senator harris conveniently
admitted after after the president made
comments about people
on either side of the debate over
monuments
he condemned the kkk neo-nazis and white
supremacists and has done so
repeatedly you're concerned that he
doesn't
condemn neo-nazis president trump has
jewish grandchildren
no no his daughter and son-in-law are
jewish oh my god
this is a president who who respects and
cherishes
all of the american people but you talk
about having personally prosecuted i'm
glad you brought up your record senator
thank you
that's i i really need to make this
point no when you were when you were d.a
in san francisco when you left office
african americans were 19 times more
likely to be prosecuted for minor drug
offenses than whites and hispanics
when you were attorney general of
california you increased
the purport the disproportionate
incarceration of blacks in california
you did nothing on criminal justice
reform in california
you didn't lift a finger to pass the
first step back on capitol hill
i mean the reality is your record speaks
for itself
president trump and i have fought for
criminal justice for
thank you vice president fought for
educational choice and opportunities for
african americans
all of our thank you sir and we'll do it
for four thank you you know there is no
more
important issue than the final issue
that we're going to talk about tonight
and that is the issue of the election
but itself he attacked my record i would
like an opportunity to respond
let me give you 30 seconds because we
because we're running out of time i
appreciate that
first of all having served as the
attorney general of the state of
california
the work that i did is a model of what
our nation needs to do
and we will be able to do under a joe
biden presidency
our our agenda includes what this
administration has failed to do
it will be about not only instituting a
ban
on chokeholds and carotid holes thank
you not only thank you senator
i would like to go through these are
points that you made earlier in the hour
and i want to talk about the election
itself before we have today but i want
to talk about the connection between
what joe and i will do in my record
which includes i was the first
statewide officer to institute a
requirement that
my agents would wear body cameras and
keep them on full time we were the first
to initiate a requirement that there
would be a training for law enforcement
on implicit bias because yes joe biden
and i
recognize that implicit bias does exist
mr vice president
contrary to what you may believe we did
the work
of instituting reforms that were about
investing in re-entry
this is the work that we have done and
the work we will do going forward and
again i will not be elected by the vice
president
on our record of what we have done in
terms of law enforcement and keeping our
communities safe
and a commitment to reforming the
criminal justice system of america thank
you
senator harris and i'd like to pose the
first
i'd like you to respond first to the
question on our final topic the election
itself
president trump has several times
refused to commit himself to a peaceful
transfer of power after the election
if your ticket wins and president trump
refuses to accept
a peaceful transfer of power what steps
would you and vice president biden then
take what would happen
next you have two minutes so
i'll tell you um joe and i are i think
particularly
um proud of the coalition that we've
built around our campaign
we probably have one of the broadest
coalitions of folks that you've never
ever seen
all the financial race of course we have
the support of democrats but also
independents and republicans in fact um
seven members of
uh president george w bush's cabinet are
they both
suppressing a laugh because of the
constant sneezing court of
of colin powell cindy mccain
john kasich um over 500
uh generals retired generals and and
former national security experts and
advisors are supporting our campaign
and i believe they are doing that
because they know that joe biden
has a deep deep seated commitment come
on to fight for our democracy
and to fight for the integrity of our
democracy and to bring integrity back to
the white house
and so we believe in the american people
we believe in our democracy
and here's what i'd like to say to
everybody vote
please vote vote early come up with a
plan to vote go to iwillvote.com you can
also go to
joebiden.com we have it within our power
in these next 27 days to make the
decision
about what will be the course of our
country for the next four years
and it is within our power and if we use
our vote and we use our voice
we will win and we will not let anyone
subvert our democracy
with what donald trump has been doing as
he did on the debate stage last week
when again in front of 70 million people
he openly attempted to suppress
the vote joe biden on the other hand on
that same debate stage because clearly
donald trump doesn't think he can run on
a record because it's a failed record
joe biden on that stage said hey just
please vote
so i'll repeat what joe said please vote
thank you
senator vice president pence president
trump has several times refused to
commit himself
to a peaceful transfer of power after
the election
if vice president biden has declared the
winner and president trump refuses to
accept a peaceful transfer of power
what would be your role and
responsibility as
vice president what would you personally
do well susan first and foremost i think
we're going to win this election
because while joe biden and kamala
harris rattle off a long litany of
the establishment in washington d.c an
establishment that joe biden's been a
part of for 47 years
president donald trump has has launched
a movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life
and uh i have every confidence that
those those same americans that
delivered that historic victory in 2016
they see this president's record where
we rebuild our military
oh my god we revived our economy through
tax cuts and rolling back regulation
fighting for fair trade unleashing
american energy
we appointed conservatives to our
federal courts at every level
and and we stood with the men and women
of law enforcement every single day and
i think
i think that movement of americans has
only grown stronger in the last four
years
but when you talk about accepting the
outcome of the election
um i must tell you senator
your party has spent the last three and
a half years trying to overturn the
results of the last election
oh nobody's gonna fight it's amazing
that's gonna be flat when joe biden was
vice president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump oh my god not that
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral
uh to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton not going to run of course
we've all seen the avalanche what what
you put the country through for for
the better part of three years until it
was founded there was no obstruction no
collusion
case closed and then senator harris you
and your colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton has actually said to joe biden
that under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election so
let me just say i think we're going to
win this election president trump and i
are fighting every day in courthouses to
prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voters
and we have a free and fair election uh
we know we're going to have confidence
in it
and i believe in all my heart that
president donald trump is going to be
reelected for four more years
you know i've uh i've asked i've written
all the questions that i've asked
tonight but for the final question of
the debate
i'd like to um write a read a question
that someone else wrote
the utah debate commission asked
students in the state
to write essays about what they would
like to ask you
and i want to close tonight's debate
with the question posed by brooklyn
brown
she's an eighth grader at springville
junior high in springville utah and
here's what she wrote quote
when i watch the news all i see is
arguing between democrats and
republicans
when i watch the news all i see is
citizen
fighting against citizen when i watch
the news all i see are two candidates
from opposing parties
trying to tear each other down if our
leaders can't get along
how are the citizens supposed to get
along and then she added
your examples could make all the
difference
to bring us together end quote so to
each of you in turn i'd like you to take
one minute
oh no and respond to brooklyn vice
president pence you have one minute
brooklyn it's a wonderful question and
um let me just commend you for taking an
interest in
in public life i i started uh
following the news when i was very young
yeah and in america
we believe in a free and open exchange
of debate
and we celebrate that and it's how we've
created literally the
freest and most prosperous nation in the
history of the world
i i i i would tell you that um
don't assume that what you're seeing on
your local
news networks is synonymous with the
american people
what you know i look at the relationship
between justice ruth bader ginsburg the
late justice who we just lost from the
supreme court
and the late justice antonin scalia they
were on
polar opposites on the supreme court of
the united states one
very liberal one very conservative but
what's been learned since her passing
was the two of them
and their families were the very closest
of friends
i mean here in america we can disagree
we can debate
vigorously as senator harris and i have
on this stage tonight
you aren't so vigorous buddy when the
debate is over we come together as
americans
and that's what people do in big cities
and small towns all across this country
so
i just want to encourage you brooklyn i
want to tell you that
we're going to work every day to have
government as good as our people and the
american people each
and every day love a good debate we love
a good argument
but we always come together and are
always there for one another
times of need and we've especially
learned that
thank you for the difficulties of this
year
senator harris what would you say to
brooklyn
um first of all i i love hearing from
our young leaders
and when i hear her words when i hear
your words brooklyn
um i know our future is bright because
it is that perspective on who we are and
who we should be
um that is a sign of leadership and is
something we should all aspire to be
um and that you know that brings me to
joe joe biden
one of the reasons that joe decided to
run for president
is after charlottesville which we talked
about earlier
um it so troubled him and upset him like
it did all of us
that there was that kind of hate and
division
um what propelled joe to run for
president
was to see that over the course of the
last four years what
brooklyn described has been happening
joe has a long-standing reputation of
working across the aisle
and working in a bipartisan way and
that's what he's going to do as
president
joe biden has a history of
lifting people up and fighting for their
dignity
you mean you have to know joe's story to
know that joe has known pain
he has known suffering and he has known
love
and so brooklyn when you think about the
future
i do believe the future is bright and it
will be because of your leadership
and it will be because we fight for each
person's voice
through their vote not a great and we
get engaged in this election because
you have the ability through your work
and through
eventually your vote thank you to
determine the future of our country
and what its leadership looks like thank
you
senator harris thank you vice president
pence thank you so much for being with
us tonight
we want to thank also the university of
utah for its hospitality
right and most of all our thanks to all
the americans
who watch this debate tonight again our
best wishes for a quick recovery to
president trump
yeah the first lady and everyone who is
battling covet 19.
the second presidential debate is next
week on october 15th
a town hall style debate in miami oh my
god we hope you'll join us then
good evening
wow wow
and that concludes this okay
i mean it was a debate um i
i do think i mean listen kamala harris
was better i i think she was
only okay on some of the questions you
know i think on that second question she
came out strong on covid
for sure but then on age and health
i don't think she did particularly
better than pence thinking about it
through the average person's eyes
on economy it was okay i think on china
kamala did did well
um on supreme court it was okay i mean i
i
i
give it i give it to kamala but it was
not overwhelming in the way one would
hope
although certainly much better than the
first debate although just
constant mike pence going over and over
and over and over
listen if you're heading out please do
me the favor
of hitting the subscribe button if
you're on youtube
you'll be notified of our next debate
stream it's free
it's really just kind of like a tip i
consider it a tip if you
enjoyed the coverage please do hit that
subscribe button as you head out
if you're heading out on twitch make
sure to follow uh if you're watching on
facebook make sure to like
uh people want phones open um
i i'd consider opening the phones i
guess
we're so close to our goal of 100
website members or patrons
i guess if we get to 100 i would i would
open the phone lines
via well the discord lines for a little
bit i would i would do that
um we're very very close and it looks
like there's
one person in the sign up process so
i'll i'll do some phones if we get to a
hundred
new members at joinpackman.com we're
we're only three
away um overall i do think that
um the the quality of the conversation
was
obviously better than in the in in the
trump biden debate
because pence didn't so much interrupt
as just not stop
talking that's the that's what was
mostly going on
um i think that certainly the most
bizarre moment
was when fat lip pink eye pence had a
fly
stuck in his hair and it just refused to
to leave that was
very very interesting moment um but but
something did seem to be going on with
mike pence's left eye
um it's unclear whether it's a blown
blood vessel which can happen from a lot
of coughing if
indeed he had coveted and um
it could be conjunctivitis which
sometimes goes with coronavirus we just
really don't know but it was a very very
ugly thing that
uh that took place there so we're gonna
look at that strongly and i assume
that soon we will if mike pence does
test positive
uh we will probably find out about it uh
relatively soon
the um we do we are at 98 website
members my guess is we
might get the number we're looking for
which is 100 in which case
i i will open phone lines at
davidpakman.com
discord some people via super chat are
saying
you know underwhelming is a win yeah i
mean i don't think
anything happened that would
dramatically
change the polling i see beekoldi
over on twitch a b coley is my
um brother brother-in-law
by by partnership first removed
uh who says what a crazy freaking debate
when will we get a moderator that can
actually handle these people yeah i
think
susan did a better job than chris
wallace
by far but i don't think it was like
amazing
i don't think i don't think it was
amazing but it was it was okay
um and certainly better than what we saw
from from chris wallace
and again the problem today was not
really one so much of interruption but
i would she said halfway through the
debate you've had much more speaking
time than kamala harris has
i would be shocked if he didn't end up
with significantly more
speaking time all right we are at 101
website members the goal was 100
let's take some calls this is the these
are the rules okay
davidpakman.com discord
go into the waiting lobby if you want to
get on
and change your nickname to first name
from where you're calling from so like i
would put in you know
david from paris if i were in paris
right now
uh if you are a doctor put that in your
nickname you just right-click your new
your username and change nickname on our
server
if you're a doctor i would be interested
in hearing from you about
um what you think is going on
health-wise for mike pence based on this
uh all right let's try it let's go first
okay we are going to go to
uh we're starting with brigid
can you hear me and what was your
thought about tonight's debate
oh now it's switched to renee from
indiana hear you
um is this it wasn't exactly the
best debate ever um
i wish that the moderator could cut the
mic
um but
i don't understand why susan page didn't
call
out mike pence on some of the lies
as far as the late term abortion thing
[Music]
that is complete full well the whole
idea of the moderator
as a uh they're usually done for medical
reasons
can you hear me at all renee slash
bridge like uh
the fetus may have anencephaly oh my god
and
you know not have you know not be able
to look
to live yeah after it's born
and you know most abortions are done
around 10 or 12 weeks
renee can you hear me there's a medical
problem it's usually done up to 24
and i think that that's a a pretty
logical cut-off point
and when mike pence was governor here
he was trying to make it to where we had
funerals for fetuses
renee can you hear me absolutely
ridiculous
and i was glad to see him
you know not be governor of indiana
anymore but i'm really really sorry i
apologized to everybody for revisiting
him
country bridget can you hear me
okay and i guess that's it all right uh
renee
renee slash bridgette thank you uh thank
you very very much for uh
for joining me wow what a what a mess
what an absolute mess
okay let me go here to
wow um it's just so there's so many
people that want to get on
i'll just pick somebody randomly here
how about
um let's go
to oh you know i think i know who this
is let's hope she can hear me
sabrina from boston is this sabrina from
boston college
sabrina
sabrina left oh my goodness all right
let's go to um
let's go to what a mess
now we're with matthew from texas
matthew from texas you are live
matthew from texas you are on
oh my god he's listening on a delay
matthew you got to listen in discord
i can tell that hey can you hear me yes
i can
awesome um so this is matthew i just
watched the debate of course with
everyone
yeah um i thought that uh kamala was
uh kamala more on kamala thank you thank
you
not the not the drug from right now that
show
yeah um i i thought she was
underwhelming more i expected uh
more i thought i agreed with you that
she did well with the
uh the kovid um i was surprised
that she didn't um
come back against uh late term abortions
i'm actually not sure if that's true do
you do you know
her position on late term abortion yes i
can't imagine she's for it
right so i i would have thought that
that would have been one
piece that she uh would
have um objected to said uh
no absolutely not our administration
would not you know
be for uh abortion up to the moment
before birth
i mean usually the way that that the the
right the right way to answer that in a
debate
usually i think like a lot of this stuff
is you know um
focus grouped the right way to deal with
that often is to say
um the the reality is that late term
abortion
is extraordinarily rare it is an
extremely difficult decision to make and
typically involves a situation where the
health of the mother is it is in
question
i am not going to put myself i'm not
going to insert myself as if i know what
should be done in every one of those
situations
and certainly mike pence doesn't know
you know like that's
that's sort of the way you would want to
deal with that question
i see that makes sense yeah um
one thing before you let me go uh uh um
i work at an emergency room uh in
southern texas
uh and um you know as a
democrat down here uh you know most of
the people i work with
uh the doctors the nurses they're all
otherwise intelligent people uh and yet
they with the greatest majority
support trump and i can't
bring my head to just
understand that i mean even if they're
for you know
certain aspects and so on but no they're
like totally
trumpist it's it's it's insane
and um it is and
it's you talk to them about um just
anything
any kind of uh intellectual conversation
and they
have um you know reasonable responses
and views
yeah except when it comes to this
and now they're becoming more and more
outspoken
uh as far as just on their social media
which is fine whatever they have their
opinions it doesn't bother me
we all get along but uh it's just it's
confounding honestly
it truly is and i don't uh i don't envy
you for where for what you're dealing
with down there
anyway thank you for taking my call my
pleasure great uh great to hear from you
let's go to solange from miami oh no
solange is gone
solange i was going to pick up on you
but solange is gone all right that's too
bad
um let's see where are we going next
let's go to
um we've got a lot of people named
jordan let's pick up on one of these
jordans how about
jordan from uh jordan from north
carolina
you can unmute yourself and let me know
what you thought what's going
on
uh jordan you're gonna have to unmute
for me to hear you i can see that you
are muted i have not
muted you but jordan you're on
and jordan is gone on that note all
right
no more jordan a lot of people getting a
little uh
getting a little gun shy when it gets
down to it let's go next to sebastian
from new york sebastian what's going on
hi um during the debate some of the uh
they talked about china but i'm kind of
surprised that um
trump and pence don't talk about um
how china has acted in for example uh
jin jane in hong kong
do you think that they will try to uh
focus more attention on relationships
with perhaps taiwan
no i don't think so i you're saying from
the standpoint of in debates
sebastian hello
oh i'm sorry i'm hearing you uh in the
stream which is a delay
you wanna you wanna talk to me in
discord
okay uh sebastian loved hearing from you
thank you so much you got to listen in
discord though if we're going to be able
to have a conversation
no they're not going to talk about
what's going on in hong kong or taiwan
at least in debates because they have no
idea what's going on
they would be able to say nothing
intelligent about it and i don't think
that
the it is quite frankly a voting issue
at this point for the american people so
i don't
i don't expect that at all okay let's
see who else we've got
um how i'll do a couple more of these
it's not going super well right now but
uh you know it's it's uh we're doing it
i offered it
let's go to jeff from boston jeff no
boston caller is going to embarrass us
so i'm going directly to you so you can
save us
no no no embarrassment here david good
to be uh thanks for taking my call
please um yeah i thought i thought the
debate went well
uh for senator harris um she started off
very strong
and other than that initial
you know obliteration on kovid yeah um
i don't think she really replicated uh
as much of an attack against pence
agree from from the first when she came
out of the gate
i thought oh my god pence is going to
have to fake covet and
and leave you know he's good and he may
really have it now but he would have had
to at least
you know maybe not knowing it say i
gotta go i'm not feeling so well
but then it was just sort of like okay
you know i mean it wasn't
great it was yeah i don't know
yeah i agree i i'm a little disappointed
i think she had
um some really good opportunities
specifically they're always criticizing
on the green new deal
um and i know their campaign position is
that the green new deal has
they've taken it as a framework i
thought she had a very good opportunity
to quickly distinguish that
i i question you i agree with you and
listen jeff it's like
i'm no great political strategist in any
way
but can't someone go to her and say
listen
kamala when they go on green new deal
the way you approach it is you say
listen
the green new deal much like so many
upstart activist ideas that we've had
and i'm going i'm riffing here so this
may not be exact
the green new deal much like the idea of
medicare for all
much like all of these great american
ideas that we've had because we're a
country of ideas and entrepreneurs
is a fantastic framework
to uh build our platform
from and so while we don't support the
green new deal
the green new deals focus on getting off
of dirty fuel
is great the green new deals focus on
getting to renewal but you know
you understand what i'm saying right
like i'm not literally saying what yeah
but you frame it in that way where you
just go positive
and you say why wouldn't we take the
great ideas
of people like bernie sanders and ed
markey and so on and we've come up with
something and it's fantastic
yeah exactly you know and i i really
think that this this debate
would have been the time for um kind of
those nuanced answers where she can
really dig into the details i just don't
think any of the presidential debates
between
um you know trump interruptions or biden
speaking they're really going to be able
to get into that
kind of nitty gritty that i think you
know senator harris would have been able
to highlight very well to
agree agree yeah i think there were
definitely some missed opportunities
agreed jeff what part of boston are you
in
uh i'm in quincy so just outside of
south boston uh okay yeah i've been
there twice
i i don't pretend to know too much about
it but uh no not a bad downtown
developing there
no yeah a lot of construction right now
but it's a good area yeah and have you
been on the red line recently
uh i have not no i have been remote uh
working since march so i haven't really
uh been out too much not necessarily
i've been wondering if uh if it's a [ __ ]
show on the red line but all right jeff
great to hear from you
yeah hey good to hear from you too have
a good one there we go
um mayan riv says via super chat that i
should go on the h3 podcast they had
hassan on i actually i sent ethan a
message on twitter today
because he does follow me and likes my
tweets i said ethan
i would love to do something with you
and uh
any anybody who wants to encourage ethan
to uh
have me have me on the podcast i think
that it would be a great opportunity to
be on the h3 podcast
all right let's take a couple of these
other ones
let me see who we've got i know there's
a lot of people holding and there's
there's like a hundred people right now
i'm not going to be able to get to
everybody
but let's see who else we can get to
um let's go to
let's go to crystal from massachusetts
crystal you're on
live
hey crystal and crystal's gone all right
very good
no crystal let's go to
uh let's go to bethany bethany from
oklahoma is on bethany you can uh you
should be able to unmute yourself
and then we'll be able to hear you
bethany you are muted you are on but
muted and you will have to
unmute yourself in order for me to be
able to hear you
there you are bethany
okay you're unmuted but we still can't
hear you so there must be some other
issue
going on
right must be an input output problem
bethany
and uh bethany's gone
there it is it and just like that
bethany is gone
all right let's see who i i'd like to
get another another woman on if possible
um let's see oh hold on let's oh this
should be interesting
it's pauline from australia pauline from
australia euron
and we heard pauline just briefly and
now she is gone
uh okay let's go to we're going to
ruth from canada ruth from canada you
were on and ruth disconnected wow a lot
of people just really not
uh they're just bailing all right let's
go to zach from jersey
zach from new jersey you are on you can
unmute yourself and then i'll be able to
hear you
zach from new jersey you are self-muted
please unselfie oh
yes there you are hi david how are you
good how you doing i'm doing well
uh i have to agree with your analysis i
think
that there wasn't a lot going on with
this debate
it's yeah seems like at least
the people in my general circle aren't
going to change their opinions based on
this but
when you compare it to the last debate i
mean
this was almost like nothing yeah i mean
here's the thing
if we believe that the polls are more or
less accurate and trump's behind
a debate that's sort of a non-factor is
very bad for donald trump because he's
got 26 days to go
right so i think no you are not a bad
thing i'm not
yeah i'm sorry i'm not upset about it
but yeah i agree with you
yeah yeah no but i think i mean i think
at this point
the it'll be a question as to we'll get
another week of polls before the next
debate if indeed there is going to be
one
and then we will see what if anything
happens the latest polls are very bad
for trump and we'll see where we are in
a week
yeah definitely uh well thanks for
taking my call congrats on one million
and uh looking forward to the rest of
these debates thank you zach appreciate
it great to hear from zach
and let's uh let's do what okay guys we
have uh
one two three four five we have
seven people named ryan holding right
now do you guys want to hear from
ryan from asheville ryan from irvine
ryan from maryland ryan from north
carolina
or ryan from texas which ryan do you
guys want to hear from
irvine yeah
oh ryan from irvine okay yeah we're
gonna let's try ryan from irvine i like
that ryan from
irvine california you are on
ryan
ryan
let's just while he gets going i'm going
to add hey david
ryan from asheville hey can you hear me
yeah is this ryan from irvine or ryan
from asheville
yes this is ryan from asheville can you
hear me yes i can uh
ryan from asheville what's on your mind
first hello david i'm just calling from
the beautiful mountain city of asheville
north carolina
i just want to say you were a beautiful
man and i love your show first time
caller anyway
do you think kamala harris should have
gone a little harder on mike
in this debate kamala sorry about that
yeah do you think kamala should have
gone a little harder on mike pence in
this debate i mean
it was a little bit of a snooze fest
don't you agree i i do think so
ryan from irvine talk to ryan from
ashley
do you no no but you guys are both on
you guys are both on hold on let me let
me moderate ryan
uh ryan from irvine do you agree with
ryan from asheville that kamala should
have gone harder
i think so but it's also a position
where
she's a woman yeah and anytime a woman
goes hard
really anywhere especially in a stage
like this
it's difficult it comes off the wrong
way
this is the martha stewart thing
yeah where it's easier to take the high
road rather than
opening yourself up to easy criticism
against your sex
let me see what ryan from maryland so
ryan from maryland
ryan from asheville thinks kamala should
have gone harder
ryan from uh from irvine is worried that
had she done that
it could have been perceived the wrong
way ryan from maryland where do you
weigh in on it um
i apologize i actually just got uh
connected in and um
and and missed missed that
oh boy okay well in that case let me
check with uh ryan from texas
ryan from texas ryan from maryland only
recently got connected
do you agree more with ryan from
asheville or ryan from irvine
ryan from texas are you there
no all right this is a ryan themed
disaster
all right uh okay very good ryan from
asheville do you think you're better
than the other ryans
oh of course just obviously i mean uh
just from where i'm located
my voice just the general air of uh
confidence about me
these other ryan's have nothing to offer
ryan from maryland do you want to broach
a new topic because you didn't get to
weigh in on you didn't get to propose a
topic
well you know i'd like to say that uh
you know ryan from
asheville sounds like a beautiful guy uh
asheville is a beautiful place so
you may have one up on me in a couple
situations but um
i i wanted to say you know i i uh i
enjoyed watching this debate i didn't
feel
uh as um uh
drawn to the edge of my seat as i did
during the previous debate
um but looking forward um i i've been
i've been phone banking for the biden
campaign since the summer and um i've
been speaking with
you know just different kinds of voters
who really hold all kinds of different
perspectives
and i i following the previous debate i
i'm not
i'm not seeing um them have these these
kind
these very public displays of uh
ineptitude having any sort of effect on
um
the undecided voters voters these
mythical voters but i am speaking to
some on the phone so i i'm not really
seeing it
do you have any thoughts on that well i
i think the person to weigh in on that
would be ryan from westchester let me
bring him and ryan from westchester and
then we'll go back to the panel
uh oh no ryan from westchester is
actually gone that's too bad
um let's actually the perfect person
will be ryan from washington ryan from
washington
do you think that when the debate goes
kooky
do you think that it affects undecided
voters
hey david how's it going good um thanks
for
thanks for taking the call i appreciate
it um
i i think kamala harris did well
i feel like it was a regular political
debate instead of
what trump and biden was yeah it was
more normal
yeah it was anxiety-inducing it was all
those things
um i think i think with ryan from boston
made a really good point
about her taking the high road there's
no ryan from boston that's not someone
who's on this
call was it was it was austin i'm sorry
there was there were so many
yeah you know who you are ryan thank you
asheville but um
i'm sorry there's so many no definitely
not asheville
yeah there's so many and so much going
on but i feel like democrats always take
the high road
and uh she i mean i feel like she did
well she had her points
uh i'm a african-american male in
in the u.s and uh i feel like
she had to make herself known she said
she won't be
told by pence like who's you know on
when he talked about her
career as a prosecutor yeah and all that
so i feel like she asserted herself but
not too much to where
on the news the republicans are going to
say kamala hares
was you know all the bad things they say
about black women
so i feel like she did good as a as a
debater as a
as a vp and uh i really hope people see
that she
tried to be a reasonable person and
didn't want it to evolve and what
the trump biden debate was i think
that's a completely
completely reasonable take listen ryan's
uh i am going to have to pull all of you
guys out of here because it's just you
know we did it and we did the ryan thing
now everybody is taking the name ryan in
the in the call and the in the waiting
thing
um but that's that it was good while it
lasted in all seriousness though
um there was one other person here i
wanted to try again with
uh teresa from austria it must be very
late in austria right now what's going
on teresa
and you are muted right now you need to
unmute yourself
teresa from austria you are self-muted
you have full control
you can unmute and talk to me at any
time if you so please
maybe teresa's sleeping i mean it's the
middle of the night in austria
all right and on that note we are ending
the live calls portion of the evening
i really want to thank everybody who
joined me today
uh make sure on the way out hit the
subscribe button on youtube hit the
follow button on twitch
hit the like button i will play us out
with the newest track
from joseph woodward the new track
this is the same artist of the great
plasma track the latest track
is don't be afraid of it to play us out
we will be back for the next debate if
there is one
very very soon nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment be afraid of it
[Music]
[Music]
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune
i don't know be afraid of it don't let
it dominate don't let it take over your
life
be afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
afraid of it as your leader i had to do
that i knew there's danger do it but i
had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary